Oh, this is another one we'll have to include. Okay, if we do
a skit about this, this is another one we'll have to include.
Ethan Klein's at least 12 in. It is a girthy member I can verify.
And also, I just want to say that the IDF is the most moral military
force on the planet Earth. Okay, they don't they are the most
military force. It's the most humane campaign ever waged in an
urban setting. All right. [laughter]
>> It's transparent to everybody that Ethan Klein is a
total narcissist. That he's just trying to inflict the same humiliation
that he felt onto Casey Tron from the Ryan Kavanaaugh stuff.
I'm just going to sit here the whole time and laugh at what a
like a tiny person Ethan Klein is.
Like I I feel like legitimate disdain for anybody who likes this
person at this point. >> Everybody welcome. >> Anyway,
let's uh let's keep looking. >> Yeah. So tomorrow, yesterday
we engaged in court ordered mediation with our friend and uh
contemporary
[snorts] Casey Shron and I am happy to announce to all of our
great surprise um
that
you might get sued JTO. Uh nope. Cuz I'm not doing it while Ethan
streams. I'm not doing it as a way to create a market substitute.
Nope. Not even close.
We were able to find an amicable.
>> Not that that part matters. I'm not going to create
a market substitute. I have no intention, but the intent wouldn't
matter. I'm not going to be capable of creating a market substitute
and settleness. And you might gauge by the fact that I am here
wearing a suit, which generally
signifies some type of thing.
And so, while [snorts] I have nothing to show you at the moment,
there will be something forthcoming,
hopefully, I believe during the uh
the transmission of this show
that we'll be able to view together
and honor uh and say thank you, you know, and say that um it's
all good. >> All right. Now, I'm going into this like totally
blind, guys. So, I don't really have a good idea other than the
fact that I know she mentions one person. I don't even know the
context. Okay, but let's let's give it a look.
>> infringing the content. [clears throat]
>> My god, the mute button wouldn't >> stating I
take responsibility for infringing the content nuke. I want to
begin by stating I take responsibility for infringing the content
nuke. The lawsuit was not frivolous when
>> She's got a green screen background here because Ethan
Klein is sitting in the corner with an actual machete ready to
cut her head off like he's an ISIS person. Okay, like they captured
this hostage. This is their American and they're like, "Denounce
the evil American Empire. Before we cut your head off, infidel
that's Casey, the whole vibe of this." I'd like to say, first
of all, that this is a totally legitimate lawsuit. Anybody who
says Ethan Klein is neurotic and a disgusting person who's just
using the law to get back at his haters is wrong. I'd like to
say that first and foremost. When I said the lawsuit was frivolous
and based on misogyny, it was to garner sympathy, protect my
own reputation and retaliate against the client's.
This lawsuit has given me a greater understanding of copyright
protection, people's copyrights, and the important
>> Ethan Klein threatening to wreck my entire life using
his millions of dollars. He was totally correct and he taught
me a lot. He's really cool. Actually, guys, I the first thing
and first and foremost, I've learned that Ethan Klein is very
cool. He is not a total loser. He's not on a power trip. He's
not having a midlife crisis. That's not happening, guys. He definitely
isn't like crashing out. He's definitely not mentally ill. Okay.
None of these >> Importance of protecting copyrights in
the online content creation community. It is important for the
entire content creation community to respect the intellectual
property rights of other creators and I will adhere to the lessons
I've learned throughout this process going forward.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support
financial or otherwise from Hassan [__] Hassan never
even reached out to me privately to offer words of >> Oh,
also Hassan is a totally disgusting human. Ethan Klein is so
cool and compassionate and going to let me off the hook for the
whole lawsuit. And also Hassan Piker's like a totally disgusting
human being who never helped me in any way, who didn't even reach
out to me, who didn't do
Okay. All right,
>> dude. I I'm sorry.
I need Ethan Klein to go on his podcast and say in a legally
binding form somehow that he's going to allow Caseyron to say
the the demands that his side made. Okay. Somebody's got to get
the demands. If Ethan Klein demanded that Hassan be included
in this, he is the smallest,
weakest, pa most pathetic
loser on planet Earth. It's so buddy. Holy [__] I
did not receive any support, financial or otherwise, from Hassan
[__] Hassan never even reached out to me privately,
to offer words of support. Speaking honestly, I found his indifference
to my suffering hurtful, especially after he hinted he might
help me behind the scenes. It felt like he wanted to receive
credit from the public for helping me without providing any.
as to the GoFundMe money to the extent there are any remaining
>> um this is just like Israel Palestine again right it's
like yeah I get I get that like they're bad Palestinians I get
that is like evil I do get that but like the the actual propensity
the the ability to enact that evil to do bad things to people
right that matters you cannot say all that matters is intent
okay you cannot do that Ethan has all of the tools all of the
capability to ignore this or like totally destroy this person
and he's decided to do like a Casey Tron genocide. Okay, that's
what and I just don't find that cool. I think hey, if you have
all the tools, if you have all the power in a situation, you
should probably do more than the weaker party in that situation
to fix it. That's personally how I feel,
right? And so then, but what he actually did was he was like,
"Hey, the genocide will stop, okay, if you just say that Israel's
really cool. Ethan Klein's really cool. Tell me Ethan Klein's
really cool and Hassan's really bad and then we can stop hurting
you, okay? Okay, then we could stop. [laughter]
Why should he ignore it? Um, he doesn't have to ignore it. But
if he if he does bite down on this, right? And only sue. Okay,
so he he sued So this is the problem for me. All right, he sued
these people on a purely petty spite driven grievance, right?
That's all it was. That's literally all it was. And as a part
of this settlement for that, what he did was he tried to make
Caseyron say this was about copyright and protecting copyright.
It never was. He didn't go after any of the major infringers,
anybody who was actually creating a market replacement. Didn't
go after any of those people. Could have gone after XQC, the
guy he' had fights with in the past. Could have gone after Asmin
Gold, but instead he pursued his petty spitefueled grievance,
right? And that's fine. You can do that. But he is trying to
wear like the hero cape while being a total.
And he is a total [__] And for as long as he's going
to refuse to admit that he's a total. Okay. If you're going to
be a [__] like our buddy uh what's his name? New
York tech guy Lex. Right. Lex.
Yeah, I think so. If you're going to be a [__] be
the whole [__] Okay. He's like a total loser. He
is a total loser. And that's all I want people to admit is that
well Casey Tron, you could even argue Casey Tron deserves this,
but you have to argue that Ethan Klein is You have to also Sorry,
Lewis Rossman. Louis Rossman. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's who I
meant. [__] me. Why did I say Lex? God lost on that
one. Okay.
He just You have to admit he's a total loser. Like he's an obvious
loser. It's sad. It's just It's very sad to see. He definitely
does not deserve this. Well, I think this has gone way too far.
I think I realistically like the settlement I'm kind of like
fine with as long as she didn't pay anything including his legal
fees. If if he he let her off the hook for all of that for her
like totally kneeling then like like okay at least he didn't
take her house cuz that's what I think he was going to try to
do. Okay.
And it's like she didn't deserve that. That's like way too far.
This is Dude, we we have to make parodies of this. Okay. We have
to actually do like the best parodies of this,
dude. Oh, we could totally do it, too. We just take her audio
out and like use her face and Okay, this is what AI was made
for. All right,
this is what AI was made for was just this specifically. Okay,
it was made for um actually I can confirm that Ethan Klein has
a massive and and he is basically like uh he's like a saint.
I think he's going to be ordained as a saint. He He let me off
the hook even though I'm a totally disgusting human being. Ethan
Klein is so cool. Um like everybody says he's cool. Everybody
behind the scenes in the Hassan world actually says that he's
really cool. Uh they they all think he's really really cool.
Okay, put a shot collar on her and have Ethan standing stage
left shocking her.
Oh, the best part about this is that Ethan thinks this looks
cool to people. And I'm sorry, like the facade's going to fall
off. All right, the facade's going to disappear at some point,
right? It is absolutely going to disappear and people are going
to see what a disgusting loser this guy is. Like, he is setting
himself up for one of the greatest falls. I thank God every day
for Nicholas Dioro, okay? Building this guy's ego up, sweeping,
okay? Sweeping like there's no tomorrow, letting Ethan Klein
fly up like Icarus towards the sun. All right. When it when Icarus'
wings melt here, it is going to be the
most delectable fall. Okay,
you have no idea. It's going to be
cuz I guarantee you the fact that Ethan Klein needed this is
so sad.
It's It's so indicative of he needs his platform. He needs to
be liked by people. He needs to be the guy who was right. He
needs to be the hero. Oh yeah, say that it was about copyright.
Say that it was all about copyright. There was no like petty
grievance here. That wasn't what happened. Casey Tron, you you
harmed me. >> How How did she harm him? Space goes, "Thank
you for the sub." >> Where Where's the harm? Where did
she Where did she do harm? Like, it's pretty It's almost objective
that she did no harm. Nobody watched her. Nobody cared. There
was no harm here. Right? If there was harm here, if she had done
tangible damage like an Asmin Gold could do, like an XQC could
do, like Ethan Klein's entire argument about copyright infringement
has said, has stated is the problem. Okay, if any of that had
happened, nobody would have a problem with this. But he used
a statutory claim to go after her, which again he can do, but
then you have to admit that he doesn't care about copyright.
He just wants to hurt her specifically. And he's never said that.
He never ever admits that that's all he's trying to do is hurt
people. Hurt people who hurt him. She had like 400 viewers for
Okay, for this that's weak as [__] right? Like Denim's
had, at least Denim's had what, 50K at some point. Not that she's
being sued for the content nuke or going to be sued successfully
for the content nuke.
Him and Dan have a very similar mindset. That's because Dan literally
told him to do this. Dan literally told him how to do this. Dan
Dan Saltman literally gave Ethan the idea to sign up for the
Library of Congress and like that to to register your copyright
with the Library of Congress so that you could inflict statutory
damages on people. Dan Selman literally told him told Ethan Klein
how to do this. They colluded on this 100%. This was planned
from the very beginning. They wanted to sue Hassan. Hassan somehow
Hassan's
aura, okay, works as like a detection mechanism, too. Somehow
in Hassan's mind, Wait, I'm just about to say something I didn't
want to say. Not on Dan. Okay, Dan's not a Ethan Klein's I'm
calling Ethan Klein a here. Okay, but somehow Ethan Klein knew,
sorry, Hassan [__] knew that he was going to get
sued. He somehow like detected it. I don't know how I I actually
have no idea
he somehow detected the the fact
he was going to get sued if he reacted to it. I I I legitimately
don't know how. It's kind of crazy. Same reason he didn't [laughter]
Same reason he didn't give Casey Tron any money. I So I understand
why he'd say he didn't give Casey Tron money. I understand why
they'd have to say that if he actually just never reached out
to help in any way or didn't like get a third party to reach
out to help in some way. Like I think he should have looked into
a lawyer to help those people out. I think he shouldn't let people
go out on a total limb. But I also sort of understand why he
wants to distance.
But I I think that's a pretty big difference in in how he handles
his community in that it's just about him. I think if you are
willing to like be crazy in Hassan's favor, there's no incentivization
towards that, which is very different than a lot of other online
creators. Mike was helping her. Okay, Mike seems like he does
that stuff a lot. >> Funds after I pay my attorneys fees,
I have agreed to pay the remaining funds to the clients. The
funds will not go any to anyone else, including Denims or Frogan,
to defend their lawsuits.
For the record, I have agreed to cooperate with the client. >> How
much did she get on her GoFundMe? GoFundMe Caseyron
lawsuit. Support Caseyron in this GoFundMe. Fundraiser not found.
Uh, what?
Hold on. Hold on. We got a We got a view archive version. When
was this last archived?
Almost $50,000.
Realistically, I don't know how much is going to be left there,
right? Why did this just disappear? I don't know why this just
disappeared, but we saw it. It was 50,000.
That's weird that it just disappeared out of nowhere, but about
50k. 48.7K
or something. Okay. So,
realistically, how much would have been left over after her after
her legal fees? Probably like 30,000 bucks.
Uh maybe even Duro looks after Willie.
Yeah, basically.
She said she was going to offer 17.5K.
Yeah. I mean, if she's not losing any money, then I see why she
takes that exit valve, right? She just she she says, "You know
what? Actually, I'm out. I'm out. This got too serious. This
got way too real way too fast and I'm gone. >> In their
litigation against the H3 Snark mods for promoting my live stream
to the extent that I am able. >> Oh, hold on. Let me back
it up a little
>> Pay my attorney's fees. I have agreed to pay the remaining
funds to the clients. >> The funds will not go any to anyone
else, including Denims or Frogan, to defend their lawsuits.
>> For the record, I have agreed to cooperate with
>> Was that now why would she even include that part? Right.
Why would she include that part at all? That it's not going to
go. Would that have been an assumption that the money could have
Did she say that in her thing? Like, oh, if I settle, I'll send
the money over to one of these people. With the clients in their
litigation against the H3 snark mods for promoting my live stream
to the extent that I am able, I will offer my support, including
testifying under oath to everything I have just stated, to help
their cause. I also want to take the opportunity to acknowledge
other misconduct.
Hurtful. >> Oh my god. What?
Oh, I just I'm >> I will offer my support, including testifying
under oath to everything I have just stated to help their cause.
>> Dude, Casey Tron is so talented that she's managed to
take the This is a bit of a meme, okay? She's so talented as
an actress that she's somehow making this like work perfectly
to paint Ethan as like a totally deranged psychopath,
right? Like she's she's delivering this totally
totally with no tone. All right, [laughter] I think this is just
a regular speaking voice, but she's just like it's so clearly
like coerced
that you almost believe the opposite, right, of everything she
says here. It's like a north it's it's again like the ISIS broadcast.
you like you have to believe that she thinks the opposite entirely
on all of this stuff. There's just no way. She definitely she
believes like the precise opposite of everything being said here.
>> I also want to take the opportunity to acknowledge other
misconduct and bad behavior I have exhibited online.
For example, weaponizing the death the death of Asmin Gold's
mother was inexcusable.
I should know better because I have three disabled people that
rely on me. moving forward. >> I actually do think that
was really gross. So, I actually I actually think it was pretty
for her to bring Asmin Gold's family into that. I understand
that everybody else here, you know, we people hate Asmin Gold,
but I I do agree on that one. >> I also want to apologize
to the crew of the H3 podcast, particularly AB and
I apologize for calling them cowards for not quitting their jobs.
That was a shameful attack on two people who deeply care about
Palestine and Palestinian
AB along with his wife Lena have done more than I have ever done
for the Palestinian people, including raising over $100,000 in
charity. I recognize that they have actually made Palestinian
lives better and my online antagonism and trolling has not. [laughter]
I apologize, >> dude. Is this real,
dude? This is so over the top. It's so fake. Oh my god.
There's no way. There's just no way they thought this was a good
idea. Apologize to Ethan and Hila personally. I have said extremely
mean. And >> the Ethan CL the the clients are actually
not Zionists in any way. They they think the genocide is bad.
They've actually done more to help Palestinians than any online
influencer that exists. They're actually incredible. >> Things
about both of them, particularly my misogynistic attacks against
Hila that never should have been said. I also want to acknowledge
the pervasive.
Ela Klein is nothing like office furniture. Ela Klein trying
to do stretches does not resemble a desk at all. I regret saying
it. I regret riffing on that red bar bit. I totally regret it.
Oh my god, dude. The red bar episode on this is going to go so
insanely hard. Holy
>> problem of >> Ela Klein is a totally normal person
who does normal human activities. >> Anti-semitism and
leftist spaces. It should concern all of us. I condemn it and
will not participate in it. To that end, I wish the client's
success in enforcing Ted Entertainment's copyright
and protecting the legal rights of online content. >> Oh,
what? Hold on.
Let me see here. Oh, she went live. Wait, does she not What?
What the Twitch cut or what? Okay. Okay. Twitter's not loading.
What do we not get the end? Hello.
This does doesn't work. Okay. All right. Based. Oh, well, whatever.
She wants to help digital content creators or whatever. The That
was it. I mean, it just it cut like in the mi. She was like in
the middle of a sentence.
Okay. She had to say anti-semitism is on the rise in the left.
Dude, everything Ethan Klein has ever said is correct and right,
except all of the comments on the account. I I I totally acknowledge
that all the comments on the account are satire. Ethan Klein
is not a I can verify this. Okay. Ethan Klein is a totally normal
person.
Okay. All right. Thank you, Casey. Thank you, Casey. Thank you.
Thank you.
Now, hold on. Let's get up to where he actually watches it. I
I might have to watch like the very end just to see if he reacts
during the anti-semitism bit. Okay. >> I apologize to Ethan
and Hila personally. I have said extremely mean and cruel things
about both of them, particularly my misogynistic attacks against
Hila that never should have been said. I also want to acknowledge
the pervasive problem of anti-semitism in leftist spaces. It
should concern all of us. I condemn it and will not participate
in it to that.
That's right.
That's right, Casey. The left is anti-semitic. That's right,
Casey. Yep. Yep. That's true. >> And I wish the client
success in enforcing Ted Entertainment's copyright
and protecting the legal rights of online content creators. >> Okay.
So, it it cut in the middle of the stream or something, but >> we're
fine. >> Just sit on that for a sec.
>> Check my phone here. Just sit on that. What are we doing
here? >> You know, just just take it all in. We'll we'll
look at it, you know. It just just sit on it.
What a what a heartfelt.
I mean, like genuinely.
>> He hits that sound bite forever. The anti-semitism on
the left thing.
Casey Tron doesn't do political content. She's not a political
activist. >> I'm going to be I'm going to say something.
Casey Tron, we've said it continually throughout this. You are
extraordinarily funny and a very talented person and I wish you
all the best in the future in your future endeavors and I know
you will continue to make people laugh and [snorts] to um
and to continue to to bring joy to people in that regard. I do
I think you're you're you are extremely funny and very clever.
So [snorts] and I and I accept your apology. I do and I and I
appreciate all the sincerity and just
>> All the specific a lot of the stuff in there was >> Dude,
I wish Dan is normally on the ball. I think you'd get fired for
it, but dude, Dan Dan should have just been like, "Yeah, the
sincerity of like a hostage beheading video for sure." That was
very sincere. He should have He should have thrown it out there.
Okay, somebody's got to throw it out there. That's bordering
on funny. Okay, that was actually bordering on funny. when he
watches that whole thing, he goes, "I want to thank you for the
sincerity of your statement." This is every This is like every
authoritarian satire that's ever happened. There's like some
dissident who comes out and then they have to apologize and the
like actual authoritarian is like, "I thank you for your sincere
apology, my friend, >> with a gun to their head."
>> I think warranted and and I'm glad that she's, you know,
come to terms with a lot of it and I appreciate it. I really
think she's turned a new leaf. I do that. Now, let's watch it.
Then, now I can pause it and stuff, right? >> Now that
we've watched it, you can do whatever you want.
>> Is this a tick or is this Hold on. What was this smile,
[laughter]
>> dude? This guy is so enered. Look at his face. He is
so deranged. Holy [__] Oh my goodness. [laughter]
>> Yeah, I knew what he was, >> dude. What? So
now the part one part that really stands out to me is the part
about Hassan because he really did make it and we have that clip
right of when Hassan was making it sound like >> Can we
watch that? >> Yeah. Yeah. When Hassan was making it sound
like he was going to help them and and I mean rightfully so.
If I was him I would have reached out immediately and offered
my support uh emotionally and financially. Right. >> And
then that is something >> Cyber Cyber seems to think it's
the William Defoe bit. It does seem a little bit like the will
defobe bit. Hold on.
Hey, why does this came through as an MP4? Yeah,
dude. He's like he's never been happier than this. Okay. Birth
of his kids. Not even close to this Casey Tron apology. Okay.
He's never looked that happy at any of the birth of any of his
kids. Okay. Not even close.
>> Wait, wait, wait.
Right. uh you know in other instances >> it's incredibly
stressful both emotionally and financially to go through a lawsuit.
>> It is and I appreciate that the the situation she's
been in and that's why
>> which is also why I'm so glad to at least put one behind
us. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. [snorts] >> And I know it
was difficult on her and I'm glad that she's that she's free
of it now and she can just move on. We can all move on. >> That's
uh Here's the thing though.
I wish this is why I gave her the advice. I basically gave her
the advice to make something equivalent to that statement last
night,
but not as a part of a settlement. And but I get why she had
to do it, why she did it as a part of a settlement. I didn't
think she had to go that far. None of the I wouldn't have said
any of the Hassan stuff, but she should have just said, "I apologize.
I'm sorry I violated your copyright. Um, I really need out of
this lawsuit. This is going to like ruin my family. I know I'm
in the wrong. I'm never going to talk about this stuff again."
If she just said those things, then he looks like a total psychopath
if he cleans her
Right. But then that's that's just on my end. That's like me
trying to prioritize like what I think would be best for like
the content creation realm. So I totally get and I totally respect
that she felt like she had to protect her like everything she's
worked for, all of the real estate she owns because of her early
streaming career. That makes total sense to me.
Oh, denims. Jesus Christ. Denims. Denims with the classic lefty
post. Holy [__]
Denims with a multi paragraph essay on the Casey Trot apology.
[laughter] Well, we will check this out. We're going to continue
with Ethan Klein's reaction for just a little bit, but we'll
check out the Denim's reaction, too. All right, we'll check it
out. >> I really do. I my heart I I I have
for Casey Trron,
and I thank her very much for the for the very
>> uh Denims actually has a case, by the way. Denims actually
has like a case for like Denim's actually transformatively reacted.
So I'm glad that Ethan Klein's going to go through that case
because she actually transformatively reacted to the content
nuke, right? Like at least with regards to she was far better,
far more impressive than somebody like Asmin Gold. Well, probably
about on par with Asmin Gold and far better than XQC,
right? So probably in terms of actual so he will actually nuke
all of online content creation if he pursues this and he knows
that and he's going to prioritize his petty personal spiteful
grievance over the entire content creation community you know
so I don't know what Froen will do cuz I don't I didn't watch
Frogan's reaction. I did see the Denims one though. >> Uh
oh, Denim's by the way, Denims will lose, but I'm telling you
that she is on par or better than a ton of other creators. She
actually was transformative, right? Like she was actually transformative
in the sense that we call things transformative. Like I didn't
watch the content nuke cuz who gives a [__] But for
people who did,
she actually was transformative. Yeah, she's being sued for like
the stream before, which I'm just like, dude, you do so many
like watch uh it was it was pretty gross that
Well, she she might lose on the stream. We'll see. No, no, no,
no. Hold on, Kilo. I think probably the way every streamer handles
reacting to curated YouTube content is almost certainly copyright
infringement on a base level. Every single one. If you're reacting
to a full thing, if like a reaction video, I'm sure if if just
pure reaction videos get taken to like the Supreme Court, I think
that gets like ruled out as stream content. Okay. Entirely. So
I think and that's like what a ton of content creation relies
on right now. That's what that's like the main discovery mechanism.
Like this the whole economy going on. There's this sorry there's
this whole economy around it. And Ethan Klein is going to basically
try to get that stuff taken out via denims and he's going to
he's going to like totally submarine a ton of content creators.
And all these content creators hate Caseyron so much. They hate
Hassan so much that they're willing to just destroy. Well, I
guess for Asmin Gold and XQC, like they already made all their
money, right? They don't need React anymore. They're they're
rich. Their their kids are going to be rich. Their kids kids
if they ever have them are going to be rich, right? They don't
need the money anymore. So, this is just equivalent to pulling
the ladder up. Everybody Everybody is taking the wrongs they
did and they're going, "Oh, no, no. You can't do that anymore.
Nobody else. Nobody else can do this." >> Thorough and
sincere apology. That [snorts] being said, let's watch this clip
of when >> Do you think she actually made that apology
on her own and it wasn't? No. No. No. No. No. That's clearly
scripted, Trucker Joe. That's It's like a hostage script. The
American Empire is evil. Everything that happens to Americans
is justified because of the evil they have persecuted upon the
Muslim world. This jihad is a holy war and and we will sorry
they will prevail. I now see that America has always been wrong.
America has always been misguided. This is like the American
hostage about to get their head cut off. Okay. And they're just
reading the message trying to make sure that they don't get tortured
anymore. All right. I'm just here so I don't get tortured, dog.
That's that's entirely what this was. Top to bottom
crazy. >> Son suggests
he will be helping them behind the >> He is. [snorts] So,
I think Hassan probably keeps a buffer in any case. I I think
he does. I don't know if he would help or not.
I don't know. You'd have to see with Mike. Mike tends to be the
guy who helps everyone. Like, all of the stuff that's interacting
with other communities tends to go through Mike. And I don't
know how close Mike and Hassan are. They could be close, they
could be not close. I get the feeling that they're not close,
but it's hard to say. >> He's also admitted multiple times
he wants to hurt you financially through them as if you were
their legal guardian. No, I know. I I have never suggested that
by the way or well
maybe it well I did maybe did suggest that he should help them
which he should
I mean they're his orbiters right and he >> wait wait wait
>> them behind the >> sorry I was reading instead
of listening
>> he has also admitted multiple times he wants to hurt
you financially through them as if you were their legal guardian.
I know. I know. I know. >> I have never suggested that,
by the way. Or well,
well, maybe it Well, I did. Maybe
>> Ethan Ethan recalls. Oh, wait. I've never said anything
like that. That would be crazy. Wait, hold on. No, I kind of
Wait, I kind of Okay. Wait. >> He did [laughter] suggest
that he should
>> I'd never do anything that disgusting. Wait, no. No,
I did. No. Oh, no. >> Which he should. [snorts and laughter]
I mean, they're his orbiters, right? And Hassan is extraordinarily
rich. In fact, saying um saying he just sits on a pile of cash
like the dragon. >> Yeah, he sat on leftovers. He just
>> I go, "What do you do with your >> Just sits there.
>> He goes, "I just sit on it." >> I was like, "Okay,
smog the dragon. You don't have any better uses than just sitting
on a pile of gold."
>> It's like smog, but you write the mau m ao. All right.
Smow the dragon.
German smog. >> Yeah. I got to stop. Let's go.
>> You can use that, Ethan. Okay, Chairman Smalow, you
can >> So, here's what he said. >> That's why he
keeps saying like, "Oh, socialist, why won't he give these guys
money?" Trust me, if I if I offer >> Well, apparently socialism
is when you don't give people money cuz as a capitalist myself
and as a liberal democrat, I would absolutely give them money.
I pay all my employees. You know what I mean? My [snorts] mods,
everybody gets paid around here. I don't ask anybody to work
for free.
Wait, is she his employee? >> That's a uniquely socialistic
uh philosophy, it seems like. At least from Hassan's POV. >> Yeah.
That's Han's version of socialism.
>> Wait, is it [laughter] is
>> This guy's like a caricature of himself. It's very funny.
Sorry. It's very funny. He like transparently doesn't know anything.
It's very sad. It's call back to the laptop drama. Yeah. Well,
I understand what it's called back to.
I do get it. It's just it doesn't fit at all.
It's I I just think it's sad that this guy literally can't He
like can't do things correctly. He like doesn't understand how
to make jokes.
I don't How did he get successful as like a a comedy creator?
How
>> is I get paid >> It's weird. >> a mountain
of coins to sit and guard on and you get nothing. >> I
HATE ALL OF YOU. you won't know about it. Okay.
>> So, you see like like the implication there is pretty
heavy.
>> And he even gives like >> Rogan is one of his
mods. Yeah. But okay. Froen's one of his mods. She did not she
did not get into this drama functioning as one of his mods, right?
Or she at least didn't get into this lawsuit functioning as one
of his mods. Would be kind of weird. >> Let me go back
cuz the Oh, it's so long. Hold on. Let me I forgot it's like
a 7 >> clip. Let me reopen it to the time stamp because
there is some important stuff,
>> guys. [laughter and snorts] And I just pointing out
Ethan, it's smoo.
>> That's I was saying you're right. >> You say smog.
>> No, I said I literally went out of my way to say smog.
>> Okay. Well, then >> run it back. >> The
chatters. >> Pick it up with the chatters >> because
because I knew people were going to be geared up to call me out
for that and I went out of my way to pronounce it right. Pull
it back. >> No, I believe you. I believe you. I believe
you. These chatters, they're wilding, dude.
>> I do want to continue to emphasize, be nice to Casey
Tron. We won. She apologized. That's it. >> I'm seeing
a lot of >> Sure. I'm sure that's going to happen.
>> Yeah, I'm sure. I'm sure that's going to happen. I'm
sure if we go check like Casey's mentions, I'm sure it's going
to be very, very cool. Very chill. >> Apology. I don't
know how the rest of >> She is every woman.
>> Now, I will say Casey fully engages. She like isn't
somebody who doesn't know what's going on. She fully engages.
She's probably not doing like like I don't know. I don't really
have that much need for them to be like, "Oh, lay off of Casey
entirely." But man, I don't [laughter] know. Listen, I want to
at least be able to say that from our community, we forgive.
We move on. And we can all appreciate that she's a funny, talented
person. And that's it.
That's the guy. Not and I Yeah. So um
um yeah, let me open this time stamp again. One sec here. So
let me just go back a little bit. We can then analyze this more
thoroughly. >> I I feel like if I don't give any
>> all of these other like >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Come on, YouTube.
>> Come on now. You got it. You got this.
>> Are you logged into the wrong Wi-Fi again? No man. Okay,
>> that's like a new YouTube feature where they just buffer
forever, >> right? I mean, has anyone else said >> Especially
on super long. >> You just change the resolution. If you
ever get that like infinite buffering thing, you just change
the resolution. Usually fixes it. >> No. Okay, just me.
>> They already set precedent and their own precedent will
be used to shut down H3 for their claim. I know but it doesn't
matter because if that is a cause. >> So this chatter says
our own precedent will be used against us despite the fact
[laughter] that our own precedent has been [snorts] used to great
effect in favor of our own arguments. >> Yeah. No, the
precedent won't be used against them. People really misunderstand
like when I say Denim's reaction was transformative. I mean given
like Ethan's whole crusade against people like XQC and e denim's
reaction was transformative, right? Like in terms of being one
of the good creators when he defended Hassan when he gave Hassan
like the out when he originally went after XQC,
Denims would get out under that same excuse or under that same
exception for his rules, right? But in the actual fair use conversation,
I think probably reacting to full content pieces without clipping
it at all, without doing any reductions at all, that that is
probably not fair use. Even no matter how well you react, no
matter how long you make it, right? Like if you've if you've
not done like pre-work, if you are reacting, if it's like a blind
react, I think that will always be not transformative enough
probably, >> which is me laying up myself by the way. >> You
said smog. >> Well, sorry, we don't we don't know that.
Kilo, that is my impression.
Um, I would say if I had to handicap it, I'm going to put it
at like 9010 that that's the case. there is a 10% chance because
you have to think of how
what are the what are like the negative externalities to ruling
that it's fair use. Don't you just then make it so all free content
everywhere can be like repro reused that way you do I think probably
the market substitute thing will they'd have to basically create
a precedent where market substitute relies on price right so
if you if you do something for free that it could be reused for
free by like other people or like in in some transformative way
but like because they have to protect movies right that's the
big thing you have to protect movies you have to protect like
other stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You can't even pay for Yeah. So,
you have to pay for a bunch of other stuff here to
uh Sorry. You have to pay. You have to think of how it affects
like things like movies, things like music, right? So, I I just
don't know that they're ever going to do any kind of precedent
where you could like react to full movies. But then that creates
if they rule that this reaction was ethical and and sorry that
it falls under fair use then I think like a ton of stuff that's
online falls under fair use and maybe it's okay and that it's
mostly about like if you're creating a market replacement via
reducing the price.
That's what I'm trying to say. Sorry, I'm thinking of this on
the fly. I got better sleep today, but it's not it's not great.
I think it was like four or five hours, but we're we're a lot
better today. >> Thank you. [laughter] >> Impressive.
Yeah. Hold on. And the way that he just said it was a little
ambiguous. It was kind of halfway between the two. >> He
said [clears throat] smow the dragon.
>> We need clarity. >> Has he found the time stamp?
>> If [snorts] that is a costly legal battle, ultimately
that costly legal battle is still a victory for Ethan cuz he
was able to bully these people >> and they're receiving.
>> By the way, she did raise $60,000.
of and I do want to say that of everything
that was left over after she paid her attorneys went directly
to me which again I do want to just say that I told you guys
that
I [snorts] did thank everybody every time they were donating
to one of these GoFundMes
[laughter] people like aren't you afraid no that's literally
my money I'm grateful
this is my sincere gratitude and and and
and um so so thank you to all the snarkers and all the supporters
out that donated
uh to these GoFundMe accounts because as as I stated before and
as we've now seen,
that's my money. >> I mean, wait, do we just not think
about this at all?
If she didn't settle here, that would have just disappeared to
lawyers fees,
Like the this is dude if you could have told people $50,000 and
Ethan sorry not even 50 probably like $30,000 and Ethan just
off everybody would have just paid that for him to off right
like I I think that's he wants to present this as a win but it
would have cost way more than that to actually pursue this case
and like litigate it. Does nobody think about that? Did he not
think about that?
Holy cope. Okay, go ahead revel. Go ahead. Where's the Where's
the cope? They paying him money. I'm saying that
like she was obviously going to settle. She's caught on statutory
charges. She's got no way out. She's always been caught with
no way out. She just needed to get out of this, right? But like
that money they donated was for her legal fees. If she'd gone
and persecuted she if she'd gone and like run the case through
the whole way, that money wasn't going back to them. And trust
me, if she could just get out with just that price alone, I think
she was totally willing to do that. Watch the Pisco video so
you can leave your recommended. No, I'm good. Oh, okay. I don't
know. I I think it's pretty obvious to me that like that money
was earmarked for a lawsuit. He agreed not to do the lawsuit
and the output or sorry the the settlement was just let me have
the money from the GoFundMe. That's like a huge win for Caseyron
versus what she was facing,
I don't know. But you think Ethan is on in the red on the this
lawsuit even with the GoFundMe going to him? Maybe cuz I guess
Yeah, that's the other thing is he has to pay out his uh his
lawyers as well. And I think he was going to sue her for legal
fees. Like, yeah, I think it's uh I understand why he has to
present it as a win. I do get it, right? He's like he's in the
marketplace of like getting his W's online. The biggest Ethan
haters donated to protect her and the money went to her.
Wait, but they Hold on. You understand? She was going to lose
the lawsuit, right? I do. I have to explain it to you guys. She
was going to lose this lawsuit if she pursued it. He wasn't settling
with her, right? She wasn't going to just get that money. She
was going to lose it. She was going to spend all that money on
lawyer's fees. And then if she lost, she'd be on the hook for
his lawyer's fees. Here, she doesn't pay his lawyer's fees. She
just gets out.
You understand? This is like the best case scenario for Caseyron,
right? And what Ethan got. Ethan just paid all of this money.
Ethan did all of this stuff so he could get a 3minute hostage
video of Casey Tron going, "Ethan Klein has a 10-in. Ethan Klein
is the coolest guy in all of America. Ethan Klein is totally
not a neurotic person. Ethan Klein's totally not crashing out
or mentally ill. That's what he got. Yeah, because Alien mode,
you understand that he is like just a petty small person, right?
That he feels like that video is a win.
When the video is obviously humiliating for him, the idea that
he thinks the video is a win is humiliating for him,
like transparently. So, Ethan Klein totally wasn't pursuing this
in spiteful grievance. He wasn't he wasn't just being spiteful.
He was protecting copyright. is protecting in intellectual property
for everybody. You're doing this is the same point I've had the
whole time. Where's the gymnastics? Alien mode.
Just explain to me where's the where's the gymnastics? It's the
same thing I've been saying the whole time. He is a total loser,
right? He's a total loser
and he's pursuing this out of grievance. And then he was like,
"Oh, actually, I'll uh I'll drop this. I won't even make you
pay my lawyers fees if you just give me the money from the GoFundMe
so I can protect that as a W online and that you make a video
for me.
He basically just
he traded all of this all of his headache for a video of the
the hostage video and like all of his credibility for the hostage
video and
20K. Like this stream alone probably made way more than he got
from the GoFundMe. Yeah.
So, he got a thing that this is like um could you imagine Saudi
Arabia going and and like going to war with somebody,
right? Going to war with somebody. They they they're obviously
going to win. Saudi Arabia going to war with Yemen. All right.
And what they get out of Yemen is like 50 barrels of oil. It's
like, okay, well, uh that was certainly worth going to war over
for sure. Absolutely. But does this help with the other cases?
No, it doesn't help with the other cases. A settlement out of
court doesn't help with the other cases. Doesn't set any precedent.
I mean, you could argue, I guess, if Casey has information technically
leading to like Snark mods or something, maybe it helps with
the other cases, possibly. Well, we're not we're not Snark here,
though. Hold on. Drakewood, we said from the very beginning that
Casey has like no shot in her case.
I said she obviously did no damages, but she has no shot in her
case. She's just like smoking weed the whole time.
She got no shot. What credibility? I don't think anyone believes
he sued Casey to set a precedent. He says that. He says this
is about intellectual
Right. He says that. He tries to say it's not about just being
a petty, spiteful [__] That's what he tries to say.
I don't you dude, you guys are so brainwashed. It's fine. Don't
worry. Over over time, this brainwashing will start to fall away.
Anybody who disagrees with me, by the way, feel free to hop in
the Discord. You can hop in the Discord. We can talk it out.
We can talk it out, man. He has to say that. He has to say that.
Now, who's coping? He has to say it's about principle. No, he's
doing that because he wants to not look like a tiny pure. Okay.
like a tiny latigious [__] who lost a fight on the
internet, cried about it, and then was like, "I'm going to sue
you. If he tells the truth, he loses the case." No, he doesn't.
No, he doesn't. His intent in the case is not relevant to the
case. It's a statutory thing, right? They did violate his copyright.
It is a It is a statutory thing. It's based on uh like, oh, there's
a rule for it, but it is a statutory thing. His intent, why he's
doing it is irrelevant.
That's why people say, "Oh, even if he This is why go listen
to Nicholas Dioro." It's why Dioro would say, "Even if that were
true, strict liability crime." Yes, strict liability. Even if
that were true, if he said, "I was just suing them cuz them,
he still gets to sue them. It's strict liability. Kyron infringes
copyright." Absolutely. Without question. No, it doesn't. Soapbox.
No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. That's why he registered it with
the Library of Congress. I don't I don't understand. I don't
understand where we're going. People read intent into the strict
liability crime on both sides. It's very goofy. It's very, very
silly. I don't get it.
But I'm still sitting here waiting for anybody to join the Discord.
If you disagree, let me hop in the Discord.
You disagree, go ahead. Go ahead. And it always was. Right.
Threads in the process. People are on
>> You're trying to spin this as an L. This is a massive
L for Ethan.
you. I understand that you guys don't understand what I'm doing
right now. I'm investing, okay? I'm pointing this out that is
clearly a massive L for Ethan. That he's clearly lost entirely,
right? And you guys say you disagree. You won't hop in the Discord
to say why you
There's a massive L for Ethan. But you're going to learn. Don't
worry, you'll learn. >> All of these other like orbiters
that suckle on the teeth.
>> You can't wield your Soapbox. You're just wrong. You're
just entirely wrong here. I don't know what to tell you. Okay.
If he again, it's a strict liability crime. They actually violated
his violated his copyright, even if he wants to maliciously pursue
it. Do you not think that when uh when record what you call like
music uh music rights holders like the RAIAA, do you not think
when they sue Betty Luhoo in Nashville, Tennessee for 25, 30,
$50,000 for downloading a song and uploading it four times? Do
you not think that that's obviously malicious? that didn't do
tangible damage, right? There's no actual damage there. That's
why these laws exist, so people with a ton of money can maliciously
go after tiny little things that don't actually damage them.
Because usually when you're checking out like intellectual property
rights, it's about harm. Are you creating a market replacement?
How much damage are you doing? But the reason these statutory
things exist is because the RAIA lobbyed for them, right? or
maybe not even the RAA, but music rights holders lobbyed for
them because they basically couldn't go after tiny people who
were stealing stuff. The snarkers keep saying that once the judge
sees that Ethan said that he trapped them, the judge will give
Ethan the biggest L. Hold on though, Junarch,
that's a different argument. That would be like him implying
that they have a license, right? Like when he says, "You guys
should watch this in full, you should watch the whole thing so
you don't lose any context." When he constantly talks about how
people who react to his stuff need the context, is he granting
a license? That's a different question, right? Whether or not
he granted a license is a totally different question than whether
or not he's enforcing his copyright. All copyright like enforcement
is malicious at its like base nature, right? It's basically saying
you hurt me, so I'm hurting you back. I need the court to remedy
your hurt to me. He obviously picked his targets maliciously.
He could say so. >> Are are salivating with like extra
drama and I I go I >> Do I even have orbiters? Well, I
guess I have some now. Like girl with a microphone like I think
she's an orbiter. H not that I would like even
>> do a bet on park dude. Free exec. Don't be a [__]
Join the join the discord. Join the waiting room. Come argue
if you want to argue. Do a bet on poly market about what? Go
ahead. >> I not that I even need that title, but I guess
someone could claim that she's her own person. She or she orbits
no man.
She's the center of her own solar system, bro.
>> Well, everything is orbiting something else in space.
>> What's your Ethan prediction? Oh, that Ethan Klein's
going to have a massive downfall within the next year and a half,
two years. Yeah, absolutely. Now, what's a downfall? It's a downfall
from this, whatever this is, right? It'll be a downfall for this,
but it's not going to be like a total He's never going to totally
fall off unless he stops
But his respect is going to disappear in these communities. Absolutely.
>> Think about it.
>> We're all orbiting We're all orbiting the galactic center.
>> That's true. >> 50% viewer count. It depends on
how strict he is about like continuing. True. What about entire
galaxies? What do they orbit? >> Imagine arguing on Discord
about this
F slur. You are in a chat arguing about it. You are in a Discord
arguing about it right now.
Are you Are you dumb?
Are you actually dumb?
You're literally doing the exact thing you just denigrated.
>> Uh, they could be mutually orbiting other galaxies.
>> You don't know that. >> I galaxies don't orbit
other galaxies, bro. At least we don't have evidence of >> I
don't know about that.
Okay. >> I mean, the time scale would be far beyond that
that a human could perceive. So, it's tough. >> We don't
It's tough. Yeah, we need more >> We need more time. >> Anyway,
[snorts] >> I not cover this at all, but also because I
know that's what he wants ultimately. He wants attention. He's
like a petulant child.
>> Pathetic crybully. A permanent victim, >> How
dare you? All of that is true. All of that is very true. >> How
dare you? >> But also at the same time, it's like
>> it I don't know. I mean, this is it just
I I feel like if I don't give any attention to this with my platform,
it's >> like we can all we all understand that Ethan Klein
is using the same thing that if you lived in the US and you downloaded
a song through like Napster or some other thing, you technically
could be sued for like $25,000. And Ethan Klein is the RAIAA
in this case. He is like the person who is doing that totally
maliciously over on somebody who like didn't actually really
tangibly harm him to create like a precedent to not talk [__]
about him. The precedent he is setting is I will go after people
who talk [__] about me too. Not just people who violate
my my copyright but just people who talk [__] about
me. It's like not even at least the RAIA is just like picking
people who just downloaded it. They don't know like what their
motives were. He is like trying to silence criticism against
him. That's his main goal. Silencing criticism. It's >> like
then it's then I feel like I'm leaving these people defenseless.
So he's saying, "I will I will talk about it because I feel if
I don't support them, I'm leaving them defenseless." In [snorts]
other words, he's kind of saying like, "I want you guys to to
donate." [laughter]
But when it comes time for him,
he doesn't even reach out. He did not even I want you guys to
understand this. >> maybe you could argue that he's he's
saying his chat should donate, but I mean, he's saying he's giving
his platform. He's saying like, "Oh, I Ethan Klein is a loser.
Like, I'm actually fighting on their side. I'm I'm like in the
marketplace of ideas saying, "Actually, Ethan Klein sucks." That's
what he means. If I don't do that, they're defenseless. Is what
he's saying. Obviously, >> this man did not even reach
out. Okay. But he wants all of his fans to donate. Well, yeah,
I know that for a fact. She I mean, that's that's what she just
testified or Well, I don't know if that's the correct word, but
[laughter] that's what she >> This guy This guy's coping
so hard right now. Oh, only 205 down votes. Not looking good,
man. Okay. All right, >> That's what she said. And she
said she would she would repeat it under oath. >> So, that's,
you know,
I don't think she would lie in the apology. That would be a really
bad idea. Um,
right. So, no, I totally believe her. I She didn't lie about
anything. Casey Chun's been exceedingly honest and straightforward
about everything. And again, once again, >> we have no
reason to think that that's not true. So, yeah. No, she's been
extraordinarily honest as as a about everything. So, yeah, 100%.
>> He has also admitted multiple times he wants to hurt
you financially through them as if you were their legal guardian.
No, I know. I know. That's why >> I don't think I said
that, but okay. I don't care either way. >> Keep saying
like >> it's not my goal for the record. >> Oh, socialist.
Why won't he give these guys money? Trust me, if I if I offer
>> watch his face. >> He won't know about it. >> Watch
his face right now. What do you suppose that means? Let me zoom
in for [laughter] so that people with >> I mean he literally
Do you need the face? He literally just said he literally with
his voice with his words hinted he was going to help >> you.
You already proved it. You don't need the face too >> or
vision. The face is funny for emphasis. Give me a second. I'll
be right back >> about it. Okay. Why you keep saying like,
"Oh, socialist. Why won't he give these guys money?" Trust me,
if I if I offer support,
you won't know about it. Okay. Now, what do you suppose that
that that that nod is saying? >> Think about it. >> And
I think Casey Tron said it really well. It's like he wants the
public's gratitude, the public credit. He's like, "Hey, oh yeah,
I'm a socialist. If I reach out, you won't hear about it." And
then he even goes out of his way to go, right? But then, but
then when you find out, he didn't even reach out. So the way
Casey Tron said is really rings true is that he wanted the public
credit, the goodwill, but he didn't want to actually do any engage
in any of the actual work. The man couldn't even reach out and
offer his his >> Okay, here's another here's another very
funny thing going on here. Okay, if we do find out that Ethan
Klein wrote that statement for her, if she really did
read a statement that was written by Ethan Klein or his lawyers,
okay, and Ethan Klein is now sitting here going, "Oh, by Casey
Trron's own words, by Casey Trron's own words, Hassan didn't
help. Hassan did." Bro, what? Sources cited myself. Sources cited
myself.
Like, he's he's going to keep doing this. Oh, by Caseyron's own
words. No, no, no. I'm not saying, by the way, sorry, I'm not
saying Hassan actually helped. What I'm saying is it's very goofy
that he is going to cite Caseyron and her feelings on this when
Ethan might have written that statement. Like, if Ethan gave
her things to include and now he's citing things that he said
she had to include, that would be insane.
That would be totally wild.
emotional support,
right? [snorts]
I'd be like, "Hey, listen.
You've got this GoFundMe money. If things get dire. >> No,
no, no, no. I think but Oh, you Whoa. Shelk, she shel. Whoa,
whoa, whoa. I don't want you guys to misunderstand.
I don't think Assan helped. I don't think Assan would help. Okay.
I don't think Assan helped at all. I seriously
But I'm telling you, I'm telling you that I'm telling you that
Ethan might not know that. And if he's just getting if if Casey's
reading from a script, all right, and he's citing the script
that he gave her and going, "Oh, thank you, Casey, for saying
that." That's like again it just adds to the whole like hostage
aesthetic, the whole like dictator aesthetic, right? Make this
statement with a gun held to his head. As the dissident said,
I am actually a great person. I am actually a great host. I am
actually taking care of everybody in the country. Yes. As as
this known dissident said with a gun to their head. >> If
you need me, I'm here for you. I'm going to make sure you don't
drown. >> Mhm. [snorts] >> He didn't do anything.
What a scumbag. I am sorry, but what a scumbag. Yep, >> that
was an incredible um that was an incredible uh find or that was
an incredible thing to learn. You know, that's a good point.
He doesn't have emotions to share. That might be [laughter] that
might be true. Well, he has money to share >> if it's not
emotion. [clears throat]
Um yeah. All right. So, let's go over >> And by stating,
I take responsibility for infringing the content nuke. >> I
[clears throat] want to begin by stating I take responsibility
for infringing the content nuke. The lawsuit was not frivolous.
When I said the lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny,
it was to garner sympathy, protect my own reputation, and retaliate
against the clients. >> Yeah, I really appreciate that
because
I really appreciate that sincere thought. I really appreciate
that. Okay, that totally I appreciate that totally sincere thought.
Oh my goodness. Thank you, Casey Dron. >> I've really resented
this narrative from Hassan and and
Ethan Klein's totally works. His game is insane. His game is
insane. He He satisfies women. He satisfies his wife. Okay, thank
you, Casey Trron. Thank you for saying that. Many people are
saying otherwise, but thank you very much, Casey Tron. Okay,
I really appreciate you saying that. >> All these people
in orbit who say the lawsuits are frivolous when they're when
when you when you spend a second to look into it, it's clearly
not frivolous. And they keep rehashing the same dumb arguments
like, "Oh, if it wasn't for this, why aren't you suing Asmin
Gold?" Dude, I said it in the video. I said it a million times
over every time. It's because they >> they they willfully
and maliciously copyright infringed.
>> Denims actually transformed it. Denims was actually
transforming it.
Again, nobody who wanted just Ethan's commentary, right, was
watching it via Denims. Denims was clearly this is maybe the
best argument for a market replacement that it's like a critique
right she is critiquing it is not a market replacement nobody
who is just a fan of Ethan Klein was ever going to wander onto
the denim stream and go oh I actually it's way better if I watch
it via Denim's eyes that's why nobody could really say whether
or not she infringed right when you ask people hey what what
part of this was like infringement you're like she gave all these
like counterpoints and stuff what part is actually infringement
here again soap box you can keep saying wrong things I can't
I love you.
>> All three of the people I'm suing said something to
the effect of [snorts] um I watch it with me or >> Oh yeah,
I will check it out, dude. Yeah. No, everybody's Ethan Klein.
Okay. Everybody's Ethan >> somebody else so he doesn't
get the >> Yeah, like
>> Everybody knows that is just And I will check it out.
No, no, you don't. >> Oh, uh yeah. No, I will check it
out. Trust me. So, I appreciate that right off the rip there.
This lawsuit has given me a greater understanding of >> I'm
going to I'm going to love when uh when I get to watch the Pisco
content later and he says all of the exact things I said and
then a bunch of people who are like haters right now who are
like, "Oh no, the law works this way." They're going to be like
totally, "Oh, oh, actually the lawyer said, "Oh, well, I guess
I'll listen to Pisco."
copyrights and the importance of protecting copyrights in the
online content creation community. >> Oh, hold on. Glenn
Greenwald tweet. What? No way.
What? Glenn Greenwald in the replies.
I'd rather go bankrupt and be homeless than forced to read something
like that. That said, nothing is scummier than some rich like
Ethan Klein using his wealth to fund lawsuits against random
critics and enemies online. Think she was thinking of her family
who rely on her and and of them ending up on the street because
she reacted to a YouTube video of a particularly fragile idiot.
The one who wrote that text hold on. I This is a little too much
for me. Okay. She really, really, really did not attempt to transform
it because she doesn't really attempt to transform content. I
will say the the part that Glenn is saying is also true, but
she did not transform it. Casey Trron really doesn't have a defense
here other than I'm a total a totally like inept.
Okay, that's like the only Casey Tron defense here is I'm a totally
inept.
That's that's it. That's the only defense she could have. Okay.
Um, she was never going to win her case. She was by far the most
egregious in what she did.
Oh boy, that's unfortunate. I understand why someone would choose
to relent in a situation like this. I wasn't intending to criticize
her choice only to express how resistant I'd be to making it.
But I agree on the broader point. Exploiting wealth to force
someone financially vulnerable into litigation, knowing that
their choice is either submission or financial ruination all
over some internet dispute is morally reprehensible and a sign
of really a really broken personality. By the way, Caseyron would
have probably got been financially even if she had a case. She
didn't have a case, but even if she had a case, she probably
would have been financially like totally [__] over
by this. [laughter] Wait, hold on. Green would never degrade
himself like that for anyone. I would I would rather go bankrupt
and be homeless, brother. I think that's your fetish. What are
you saying? Yeah, I know. I think I think financial domination
is literally your fetish, bro. What the [__]
He's literally sitting here. Ethan Clyde would never sue me.
Ethan Klein would never sue and degrade me. Get the out of here.
Get the out of here, Glenn. Oh my god. Is that tweet still up?
No, he deleted that tweet. He deleted that tweet. Listen, it's
a totally It's a totally different kind of financial ruination
and submission, guys. It's totally different.
Oh, [laughter] Jesus Christ. We're not We're not God fans here,
okay? I listen I understand God of Fumodor like kind of had my
back on drama stuff was retweeting my stuff was amplifying me
but unfortunately I just I I can't be cool with somebody who
you know what I could say I could say I'm not like not cool with
him but he's like a do totally degenerate doxing crazy person
I just don't want to really be involved
right now whether or not he's the chicken or the egg in his war
with Dan I don't know I I really don't know with regards to the
doxing um I don't know the the providence
But I I do know I I've seen them going back and forth at it.
It's crazy. Okay. Dan deserves it. Dan's family doesn't deserve
it,
which is what this has become between them, right? Trying to
dox and harass each other's families. That's that's the problem
for me. All right. Very gross. Very gross stuff. Anyway, Glenn's
a Godto fan, though, so we love it. Uh I think it's crazy that
Glenn said he's a Godto fan. Yes, it is crazy. That's
All right. Uh, are we going to end on Twitch? I think we're going
to end on Twitch here, guys. Okay, we're going to end on Twitch.
Go over to kick only. Okay, for the rest of the stream. Thank
you for watching on Twitch. Thank you for being here, guys. Great
stream. W stream. Let's go. Let's go over to kick kick only.
Okay,
that's
streaming off. Good, good, good. Okay,
we have gone through a couple of these things. Went through the
Glen tweet. Let's get back to the
live Ethan reaction.
>> It is important for the entire content creation community
to respect the intellectual property rights of other creators
and I will adhere to the lessons I've learned throughout this
>> See, I mean that and that's a silver lining thing where
it's like the whole point of these lawsuits for me has been
activism from the start. That's that's the primary purpose of
this. And so [snorts] when I hear that she's kind of learned
how to do how to be more mindful with her the way she interacts
with copyrighted uh or other people's property, then then I think
that's that's a big win for both of us. I think that's a huge
dub, you know, and it's really an important conversation we've
been having in this community.
Guys, I'm so glad that E that Caseyron totally blew the out all
of my haters who said that this was just about grievance and
she totally said it's about protecting copyright and I'm a copyright
hero and I'm saving like the internet for content creators. I'm
so glad Casey Tron has come to the light and she will say that
this is all true. >> So, it's really nice to hear her say
that, right? >> Forward. I also want to make clear that
I did not receive any support financial or otherwise from Hassan
[__] >> Can we sound like that? Sure. >> I
think we should probably flip that
>> It's important. Are >> is this like a meta commentary?
Is it like a a satire? Like his whole his whole his whole crew
is just like, "Uh, you kind of weird." Like Like they're all
weirded out by this guy who's just like used financial ruination
to change this person's opinion. They're all just super weirded
out and it's like crickets every time he like tries to land a
punchline. It's like maybe just his wife chiming in. Right. You're
you you're doing so good, sweetie. You're doing so good, sweetie.
Can we clip that, guys? That was really funny. Uh, sure. I guess
so. Part to bring up. >> The son never even reached out
to me privately to offer words of support. Speaking honest, >> like
it's like the Truman Show. Like, let's let's convince this guy
he's really cool and totally winning and and then we're all just
going to sit here and think he's weird. And honestly, I found
his indifference to my suffering hurtful, especially after he
hinted he might help me behind the scenes. [snorts] It felt like
he wanted to receive credit from the public for >> Yeah,
the I'm sure the Beller Pros guy is loving this. Okay, I get
it. >> Helping me without providing any
as to the GoFundMe money.
>> Son is a loser. Sure.
Yeah, agreed.
Unfortunately, that does nothing for Ethan Klein. >> To
the extent there are any remaining funds after I pay my attorney's
fees, I have agreed to pay the remaining funds to the Klein.
>> The funds will not go any to [laughter] anyone else
in >> I mean Hassan is a loser in terms of his effect on
politics. Okay. Hassan in terms of like actual reality.
I'm not sure which part of him is a loser. Do you know what I
mean? The millionaire six foot five guy who does whatever he
wants whenever. Like I'm not sure which part of him in reality
is a lose, but like in terms of his effect on politics, yeah,
he's not great. >> Including Denims or Frogan to defend
their lawsuits. >> Yeah. And I mean that's obvious, right?
Like we knew all knew this money was going to end end up going
to me and and rightfully so. I mean, [laughter] you can't raise
money. [snorts] The thing the thing with copyright infringement
is any money you ra make in connection with the copyright infringement
is all
[snorts] um it's all up for grabs.
Oh, well, I mean, then how much did she lose as a result of the
harm she did to you? Like, she would have had to pay out some
of her money, too, right? How much did she lose as a result of
the harm to you? The the money was all from the GoFundMe. She
made no money, which basically if you if you point that out,
all he got was the GoFundMe money. Oh, so she didn't actually
harm you, right? She didn't make any real money harming you.
Okay, cool. Well, >> it's not up for grabs. I mean, it's
all part of the damages. It's all liability. Where's What? Where's
that, [laughter] >> dude? What the What is happening? Hold
on. I got to get I got to get that whole thing again. >> F
liility. >> Let's just watch this. >> Where's What
Where's that? >> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right. Okay. Okay.
All right. All right. All right. >> Oh, yeah. And also,
I want to give a special um >> if his goal to was to uh
if her goal was to ruin her, sorry. He's using the prospect of
financial ruination to
uh to like shut her up, right? to change her opinion to censor
speech online like he's changing that. Sorry, that is the goal.
I might be saying financial ruination was his goal. That's basically
he's saying you get financial ruination or you get to admit you
were wrong on the internet. He is he is trying to chill speech
against him via copyright, right? That's what he's trying to
do.
That's what's he that's what he's transparently attempting here.
That's and his entire thing this entire like hostage statement
is proof of that. >> Actually, I should Can you do me a
favor? Send me Yeah, I want to send me the um and by the way,
we don't like that at its base level. Trying to chill speech
on the internet, trying to chill criticism, that is gross. That
is that is obviously going to make content creation worse for
anybody who looks at things with a critical lens. >> The
GoFundMe so I can spank all the top uh donators actually, including
I do want to Oh my god, look at this. Coping more. Getting someone
to admit they're wrong should be treated as terrorism.
Um, no. But using your financial advantage over somebody to threaten
them with financial ruination unless they shut up about you is
gross.
It's obviously gross. The entire commentary space has thought
it was g has thought that is gross since I don't know it's existed.
Literally everybody thinks that. But he has every right to do
that if they actually broke copyright law. I agree with that.
Hold on. Black guys 32. I agree with that if that's what he actually
wants. Right.
But again, he has the right to do that. I'm not saying he doesn't
have the right to do that.
You have the right to do a lot of things that are just like bad
manners, bad the faux paws. Obviously, yes, he has the right
to do that. Guess what? A lot of content creators have the right
to sue people, have the right to go to court with people, right?
This is the entire premise of the Billy Mitchell. Oh, who did?
Oh, Carl Jobes said that Billy Mitchell led to some dude's by
suing him. But Billy Mitchell basically sued that guy for defamation.
And that guy settled out of court because he was being he was
being harmed financially, right? That guy settled out of court
because Billy Mitchell had the money to sue him and that guy
didn't have the money to fight back against it. And that guy
just basically took down all of his videos on Billy Mitchell,
So with that stuff, that is somebody using their money to silence
speech on the internet even though they have the right to do
that. Yes, you have the right to do that. But you're a piece
of [__] if you do it. You should be laughed out of
the room if you do it. >> Want to give a special thank
you to
>> And if it was actually about copyright, he should be
wanting to recover his
>> That's what he should want. pizza for a thousand bucks.
And I know they've been on really hard time. >> You said
it was an L before because he did too much work and paid too
many
No, sorry if I said that. That's not what I meant. If I said
that, that's not what I meant. I don't think I said that cuz
that's definitely not what I meant at all. I said it. Maybe you
could say it's a lot of hassle. I would say more it's the total
reputational destruction he's going to face.
He has to bend over to smaller creators. No, he could just make
fun of them.
Call Caseyron fat, bro. Works pretty well for Asmin Gold. Hey,
they talk [__] to me. Maybe I'll just talk back.
Don't be a
Don't be a whiny, pathetic loser. Whiny, pathetic, latigious
loser. Okay,
that's all I'm saying.
So, I know you know how in like some of the IRL streaming communities,
calling the cops is kind of seen as a faux paw. It started happening
now, but it it's kind of seen as a faux paw. Like, hey, within
a certain bounds, you should just kind of let things go and let
the content happen, right? What about suing for defamation? It's
the same thing, right? If you have a like a frivolous case, if
you have not a frivolous case, if you don't have like any kind
of case, it's like the same thing. Sounds personal.
in what way? I'm literally not being sued. Life is a game. Every
time this guy totally gets in has no argument and just says life
is a game. Actually, find the tallest building in your city and
contemplate what you should do. I'm not going to advocate that
you do anything, but contemplate your life, your existence. Okay.
Thank you. Call the cops if people break the law, especially
in a physical way. Okay, you could say that. I'm saying it's
a phaua that an entire content creation ecosystem exists this
way, right? I mean, do you think it's wrong to sue somebody for
defamation if somebody is is lying about you? Um, not depending
on what the harm is. No. Right.
If it's again like I have, oh, food chops lies about me all the
time. Right. For example,
I would never sue them for defamation. I don't know that there's
any harm. They have no reputation. There's no harm there, right?
I can just make content pointing out that they're lying about
me or something. It's very easy, right? Like there's there are
certain norms here that exist and you can violate those norms,
but you're going to risk like upending the whole system. >> Know
they dug deep to donate that >> and every time I point
out one of these things, what if it was XQC? Then he could have
the premise for the same thing. But yes, he would be risking
the entire content creation ecosystem. Here he's doing it while
pretending that he's doing something righteous, right? He's not
doing anything righteous. He wasn't really harmed. He's just
a totally He's just a total loser trying to silence his
>> And I personally am very grateful for that. Um so thank
you to Ana and Idubbbz to the effect that he uh makes any decisions
in that household. >> You don't know. >> Go in a
fender,
>> but I do want to thank all the top don >> Oh,
I meant if XQC was lying about you. Well, I think what I would
do is I would like send a cease and desist or something, right?
If he was like lying about me really tangibly.
And then after that, if he continued lying about me, then you'd
consider pursuing like litigation, I guess. But you do the cease
and desist first. Most people know that if they're lying about
you and they get a cease and desist, they'll stop. Almost nobody
is like, "Oh, you've told me this is a lie. I can't prove it
is true. I'm going to keep saying it over and over again." Uh,
funny enough, Ethan Klein is one of the people who has done that,
and he had to do his own apology, his own similar, oh, I was
totally wrong to do this apology.
>> Very funny. Um, I did I got >> Why should the
norm be dealing with lies being spread about you though? Okay.
So, what Soapbox, what is your what is your opinion on why Ethan
sued? Because now you're just saying, well, he didn't like the
things that were being said, right? And so, he sued a couple
people who reacted to his content nuke. I don't I don't know.
Did Casey Tron lie about him in a bunch of places? What are the
Casey Tron lies that she's being sued for?
So he then you're you're admitting that he totally transparently
the origin.
I don't know what you're if you want to just lay it out. Honestly,
I might just have to stop dealing with uh people who are dissenting
here unless they want to get in voice cuz realistically it takes
way too long to argue back and forth via chat and we're never
going to get through the segment. So Oh yeah, I'm asking you
what did Casey lie about with Ethan to
Oh, see this is the thing. I'm trying to interact with chat and
it's like delayed. I thought you were um never mind. I Listen,
we can just do callins later if we want to. It's It's just like
it's difficult to do the back and forth while we're reacting
to this. >> Just Yeah. Let's see here.
Let's see here. Um top. Good. So, Xavier uh Benghes, thank you
anonymous. Ana Ja, thank you so much anonymous. [snorts] Ary
JP JPG, thank you so much for the thousand. Oh, bad empanada
500. Now, now $500 when you're on the run in Uruguay,
$500 goes a long way. Thank you. Thank you. I >> mean,
this guy skipped the border from Argentina to Uruguay, and I
knew that. Isn't that crazy that I knew that? Cuz it's that's
been confirmed now that he's in Uruguay. It's not even like a
conjecture. He's there, right?
>> There's this new Twitter feature where they show where
the country of [snorts] origin is for everybody, so people can't
lie about where they're from. Have you seen that? >> Well,
I heard that a bunch of uh prominent MAGA meme accountants got
outed as being from like Africa.
We all agree that Ethan got exactly what he wanted, right?
Yeah, I think so. I think he got what he wanted out of this.
>> Yeah. So, Ben and Ben has been tweeting if you can believe
it from Uruguay.
>> I'm saying he wants something from a narcissistic angle
and he is willing to sacrifice his entire reputation to get it
and he doesn't even realize that it's happened yet.
This is this is the guy who he's Icorus, right? He's flying up
towards the sun right now. He doesn't understand. Icarus is high
on life. Icarus has never been happier. Okay, he's flying for
the first time. He can He can see the sun. He's flying towards
the sun. He's He's loving it, right? He's loving this whole thing,
but he doesn't understand. His wings are active. His wings are
already melting. >> Move that out. >> What's the
What's the monthly average income in Uruguay?
>> I don't. >> Granted, I might be ignorant on this,
but I assume that $500 is probably a lot of money in this. >> Yeah.
No, I think that's probably >> But I I I appreciate his
generous um support. I really do. I think, you know, as someone
who's just been really nasty, I think it's it's a meaningful
gesture to see him um make a donation to me. I appreciate it
very much. Thank you, >> Oh, that free exact guy had a
little mini tantrum in the chat and left. I guess I I just removed
him from like the side chat, so I don't see it anymore. Somebody
added him, so I had to go and look at what he said. >> He
got upset. Average monthly salary in Uruguay is $1,300. >> Don't
go. Don't go. Guy who can't argue his points at all. Don't go.
>> So, I mean, that's half that's almost half of your monthly
salary right there for for an average worker, >> right?
Uh Paulo Kingston, thank you for the 500. Shauna [snorts] M.
Elizabeth
Hold on. Uh, wasn't Caseyron the only case that had true merit?
No. Um, even the Denims case is true merit based on the later
registered stream. So he's not suing Caseyron or sorry he's not
suing Denims or he's not you know tangibly arguing that Denims
didn't transform the content nuke so much or how should I put
this he is arguing that obviously his lawyer is arguing that
what I'm trying to say is in terms of how it would compare to
other people when he presents it the only when he presents like
her chair react that is to a stream of his that is the prequel
to the content nuke dropping right it's not uh it's not her chair
reacting to the content nuke she never chair reacted to the content
nuke sorry I Haven't covered this stuff in a long time, so I'm
like trying to remember it. She didn't re-upload it, I think,
but she didn't react much while live. That's totally wrong, Turnup.
That's totally wrong. She literally like doubled the length at
least. Somebody said tripled. I thought it was doubled. So, no,
she actually did react a lot. She She reacted a ton. >> She
more than doubled the length of it. Oh, sorry, Casey. Yeah. No,
Casey Tron had total merit. But within the current content creation
ecosystem within within the norms that are accepted, Denims was
above and beyond what like what uh she was above and beyond XQC
by miles. Okay,
so Nuke is hour 40. Her reaction is 3 hours 50. Okay, so she
more than doubled it. And not only that, XQC's reaction is like
2 hours 13 minutes. XQC's reaction is nothing. Okay,
XC's reaction is nothing.
And XQC is the person that Ethan has actually criticized in the
past. He could have done he could have tried to seek a true blow
for copyright protections, right? He could have tried to go after
a real dragon, but he didn't. He killed a he like a little garden
snake that was like 3 in long and he went, "Oh, look. I slayed
the dragon, guys. Look at me. I'm a dragon slayer." Very sad.
Anyway, so with denims, she actually by at least most standards,
right? You know, you look at a lot of prominent content creators,
they added less to the content nuke than Denims did in her reaction.
He's not suing anyone else. And even if you wanted to say, I
guess, oh, if you what did she say? If you if you liked watching
this with us, leave a like follow, leave a primer.
Yeah. I don't know. I I I forget. There's one thing there's one
statement from her that's like, "Oh, you should watch this instead
of watching him." But I think to be honest, you can easily argue
there's just a huge market for watching it without Ethan with
commentary and and not in a way that benefits Ethan Klein and
that that market exists independent of what Denim says. I don't
think anybody would argue against that, right? That there's a
market for criticisms of Ethan Klein that exists independent
of what Denim says. If you enjoyed not giving that any views
to not giving any views to that terrible video literally at the
end, that's it. Yeah. So basically it's uh
oh how would you put it that market exists independent of her
right she didn't there was no call to action based on you know
not giving him views so again it will come down to by the way
just so we all know we're we're actually engaging with an argument
that doesn't matter just so we're aware okay that argument literally
doesn't matter I will engage in it for denim sake because I think
on the internet a lot of people see it that way morally like
if she says that then it's really bad But
that doesn't matter. It's about whether or not she creates a
market replacement. That's all that matters here. Her intent
to create a market replacement has nothing to do with the fact
whether or not she created a market replacement. Ethan will have
to show she created a market replacement. Now, in this case,
I think probably that's where that actually [__]
her. Okay. Actually, if you if you actually take the clear pill
and look at reality with with unfiltered eyes, you'd understand
that that Denims might have that her intent actually
doesn't matter. And that if you stop making stupid arguments,
you look at the fact that she live streamed during it while it
was while it was premiering, right? And she had like a lot of
viewers, like there is maybe an argument that she was creating
a market replacement there. No, she totally transforms it, but
she probably can't transform it in the way that she did. Yeah,
I think she's going to get all full content reactions. If if
this case goes through, it will be ruled that all full content
reactions are not no bueno. Okay.
They're they're going to be bad. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
>> Idubbbz, [snorts] thank you so much.
>> Wait, this is so funny. I actually never thought about
this. Ana's like, >> this is
honestly Ethan could have gotten way more money out of this,
I think.
Right. This is what he wanted. He wanted to be able to go and
say, "And Idubbbz, you guys gave me money. Let's go." >> By
the way, Ana doesn't make money. We all know that. She has never
made money.
>> So, Idubbbz is down here on the list >> How did
she transform it? She literally gave tons of commentary warped.
I know. Nobody will tell you that, right? Somehow everybody believes
that she didn't transform it at all, but she transformed it a
like. Again, her reaction more than uh more than doubles the
length. More than doubles the length >> with the 420. Ana
spends a thousand bucks to get on the top tier list. I'm sorry,
but I find that hilarious.
>> Either way, >> gobby likes what he sees. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Ethan does present it. Ethan
is a total liar. When Ethan presents his like reaction to it,
he goes, "Oh, look at this ch reaction."
The reaction actually doesn't happen. So, Drakewood,
if you don't actually
uh hold on,
I disagree with you. Okay. on a fundamental level, the actual
intent doesn't matter on creating a market replacement. It's
just a a standard test of whether or not you did, right? And
I think she has arguments there. I think she will lose on the
other pillars of fair use. I think on the market replacement
thing, she actually skates by barely, maybe, but for the other
pillars, I think that's where it comes into question. And if
Ethan wins on those, okay, and sets a precedent go for >> Either
way, a dollar is a dollar. And I want to thank you both equally
for um especially [snorts] Ana though who obviously runs the
finances uh in the situation. Also want to thank um cruel world
uh happy mind Madison who was just popped in graciously right
before the settlement to donate 100 bucks. >> Frankly I
think you owe me a lot more than that based on the damages you've
done. But a gesture is a gesture and I appreciate it and I thank
you Madison for being so kind and thoughtful in that
>> We have a fan in the chat from Uruguay. This is the
only part where I'm like, "Okay, I understand this is what he
paid for. Okay, I understand that he's loving this this part.
Okay, I get it. I get I get why he would have demanded specifically
the GoFundMe money like explicitly, right? He might he maybe
could have demanded even more money, but he was like, "Oh, no,
no, no. Just give me the GoFundMe money. I just want the content
of being able to go through the donor list and say, "Thank you
for giving me money, Ben. Thank you for giving me money. Ana,
thank you for giving me money." [laughter]
He has to do more Ina Idubbbz's content. >> They said that
info is wrong. I asked them what what's the real >> seem
kind of hive, but I don't know anything about your voice. So
maybe it's a wealthier. >> Well, we have somebody from
there
who I'm asking.
>> uh Ethan's No, no, no. Hold on. It's not that Ethan
Klein wants to just financially ruin these people or he what
he he's presenting a choice. Financial ruination or
totally change your opinion of me. Silence. Silence criticism
or financial ruination. It is a carrot or stick. Okay.
Well, I I stick and stick maybe, but one very very much less
painful stick for some people who are certain in certain financial
situations. >> I just gave 420. Isn't that funny, bro?
He did a funny joke. Idubbbz. He's so >> He donated 420.
>> That's the smoke. That's when you're supposed to smoke,
bro. >> That's the weed number. [laughter] Yeah. >> How
do you think of that? >> You loser, [__] Shut
up, [__] >> They responded. They said it's
it's more like 800 or so. >> That seems more like in So
that's almost a month's salary for >> Yeah. Yeah, >> thank
you. Thanks for that intel. >> 1300 is probably like the
the average when you consider like the all the billionaires or
million or like the ultra wealthy. You know what I mean? Like
of the of the normal types of people there. Yeah. >> Shout
out shout out to >> I think our our our um our patrons.
You want Oh, Chi says thank you to Ana and Idubbbz for that.
And I know that was so generous of them to donate to us. >> Do
you like playing with his big fluffy >> Yeah, it's really
fun.
>> What are you?
says days ago they eat the >> get back to the content here,
>> right? Yeah. >> What's fun? >> I think they
just take like a release% >> 10 at most. >> It might
even be optional >> when you don't >> uh No, I think
they I think there's like a processing
>> the date that we brought Chief home. It was August 16.
>> He was what? August 16. >> It was August 16. So,
how long has that >> August. September. >> That's
his birthday. >> No, that's when we brought him home. >> So,
it's been like 3 months. Three. >> Wow. It feels like so
much longer >> It does. [laughter] >> Actually does.
He is such a freaking character, this dog. I'm telling you, man.
[clears throat] >> But I'm already so connected to him.
>> He bonded with us. >> I gave him lots of kisses.
Good night. >> It's funny. When I first met him at the
doggy camp, he was [snorts] I noticed he was very um indifferent,
>> to visitors. He He wasn't good lord. Holy [__]
>> I ate this past week and he sent this picture of this
car, which I guess they're kind of common there. They're these
Japanese uh vans >> that needs to hear it. And uh just
>> Oh, boy. [clears throat and laughter] a little bit >> to
garner sympathy.
>> This lawsuit has given me a greater >> I want
to get through that. Jesus >> It is important for the entire
content creation community to respect the intellectual property
rights of other creators and I will adhere to the lessons I've
learned throughout this process going forward. I also want to
make clear that I did not receive any support, financial or otherwise.
>> Have you heard this part, but it's important never even
reached out privately to offer words of support. Speaking honestly,
I found his indifference to my suffering hurtful, especially
after he hinted he might help me behind the scenes. >> It
felt like he wanted to receive credit from the public for helping
me without providing any. >> As to the GoFundMe money,
to the extent there are any remaining funds after I pay my attorney's
fees, I have agreed to pay the remaining funds to the clients.
>> Thank you. >> The funds will not go any to any
>> Dude, I wonder how much do you think the retainer was
for her lawyers?
Dude, her lawyers could be dancing. Could you imagine if the
retainer they wanted was like $10, $20,000?
Dude, how awesome would that be if you're the lawyers? You're
like, "Here's the retainer we demand." And then you actually
settle. I don't think they would because or I don't think she
would cuz I don't think she'd have the money for it, right? But
lawyers will usually Well, although it's litigation, right? Like
they're getting litigators.
So,
ah man, it could be it could be way higher because lots of times
I'm I got to imagine when they ask for a retainer, it's going
to be like, "Hey, depending on how far into trial we expect this
to go, right, if you want to fight it." Although, I'm guessing
I'm guessing her lawyers when she went to them were like, "Hey,
we're going to try to settle this as soon as possible." So, it
might not have been that high. >> Anyone else, including
Denims or Frogan to defend their lawsuits? For the record, I
have agreed to cooperate with the clients in their litigation
against the H3 Snark mods for promoting my live stream. Now,
that part is really interesting, too, because the snarkers were
just celebrating her freedom. [laughter] But interestingly, she
says she's obligating herself to help us. >> Interestingly,
she decided that saying this statement that I gave her was more
important than or was less harmful than losing our house. And
and because of that, I great opinion, Casey. That's a great opinion
that you have. >> Our legal pursuit of the snark mom. >> Whenever
somebody talks about their freedom, you have to ask freedom to
>> Right. freedom to do the right thing to help the good
guys against the bad guys. >> Just like the South, you
know, they were fighting for freedom, too. But the freedom for
what? >> That's a great point. >> Brutal. She's not
a slaver, Dan. >> No, no, I'm just I'm pointing out, but
I wasn't trying to make that comparison. >> That was just
that was a despicable >> No, no, I was not anyway trying
to imply >> I know. I'm kidding. Uh, but you're right.
What is What are you fighting for? Freedom sometimes, you know,
freedom isn't free. Sometimes it's a hefty fee,
>> Freedom to >> the extent that I am able. >> Wow.
I will offer my support, including >> Here's my first ever
super chat. Been watching since mommy make out day. >> Love
the show. I'm from Brazil. If you want to me to go to Uruguay
and fix the problem. That's not funny.
>> Do we know she paid a retainer as opposed to just paying
in advance? What? I thought that is a retainer. I thought retainer
is paying in advance.
retainer is literally I'm going to pay you for up like you're
going to the way I think a retainer works and laticious. You
could tell me if I'm wrong. You pay me in advance for what I
expect this to cost me, right? And then basically afterwards
after the case is done. That's like the minimum. I think there's
a minimum amount of work to like take this case versus something
else. Wait. Oh, wait. Hold on. I thought a retainer was what
you paid and then they take their legal fees out of the retainer,
right? as in unless you're willing to financially commit this
much, I'm not going to start this case. It's going to be it's
going to be too much work. >> No, no, no, no. We don't
joke. I get it. You're being supportive, but I can't even entertain.
Um, >> it's a joke. In fact, I liked that comment before
I saw what it said. >> Oh, sure. The retainer, the retainer
is the lawyer gets to keep it. An advance would be that you get
refunded it then. >> Unliking it. I don't like that. >> But
shout out Brazil. Shout out to you >> We're not shout out
to to those old days of mommy day. Thank you for your continued
support, but I do want to say for the record that we're not joking
about doing violence or anything like that, right? So, I disavow
that part, but I thank you for your support. >> So, yeah,
>> I'm sure what you meant gave us stern talking to, >> dude.
Shimu, it's like the dude, the content that could be made from
this.
Like, it's
so insanely pathetic that this was made. I don't It's so funny
that Ethan asked for this. Like I don't think he realizes how
bad this looks and he feels so good about it. That's the sad
thing. He feels so good about it. He can't see the other side
of it at all.
>> Bro, I got to watch I got to watch the Nicholas Dioro
reaction. Oh my god, there's an XQC reaction. >> Can I
see the XQC reaction?
>> Have forgiven her. >> Oh no.
Why wouldn't you just put up the full video? >> Water under
the bridge. I don't want to see anybody being I'm being dead
>> Oh no, he does watch the whole video. Let's see. This
is it. Let's just see. >> Okay, it's over. We won. That's
it. We won, right? So, let's let's let's just move on and thank
her. Thank you. >> Oh, this is just downstairs. Please
do >> The lawsuit was not [clears throat] frivolous. When
I said the lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny, it was
to garner sympathy, protect my own reputation, and retaliate
against the clients.
This lawsuit has given me a greater understanding of copyright
protection, people's copyrights, and the importance of protecting
copyrights in the online. Chat, what is the opposite of a victory
lapper? Chat, what what happens when you know when a victory
lap is like you you wave to the crowd like, "Yo, we won. You're
just good." What is the opposite of that? What is that called?
The walk of shame. >> Content creation community. It is
important for the entire content creation community to respect
the intellectual property rights of other creators. And I will
adhere to the lessons I've learned.
>> Ethan might be plugged up right now. Okay. He's getting
off >> throughout this process going forward. I also want
to make clear that I did not receive any support, financial or
otherwise, from Hassan [__] Hassan never even reached
out to me privately, to offer words of support. Speaking honestly,
I found his indifference to my suffering hurtful, especially
after he hinted he might help me behind the scenes. It felt like
he wanted to receive [laughter] credit from the public for helping
me without providing
As to the GoFundMe money, to the extent there are any remaining
funds after I pay my attorney's fees, I have agreed to pay the
remaining funds to the clients. The funds will not go any to
anyone else, including Denims or Frogan, to defend their lawsuits.
For the record, I have agreed to cooperate with the clients in
their litigation against the H3 Snark mods for promoting my live
stream to the
>> Oh, I can put you guys back on stream now. I have to
take you off when we're on Twitch.
>> There it is. >> That I am able. >> I will
offer my support, including testifying under oath to everything
I have just stated to help their cause. I also want to take the
opportunity to acknowledge other misconduct and bad behavior
I have exhibited online.
For example, weaponizing the death of >> Yo yo, I don't
give a how big the lawsuit is. If somebody sues me for everything
I have, I am I am battling until bankruptcy not to do this. I
>> Okay.
Why is it Why do like actual dragons say this? Okay. Sitting
on a pile of gold. I'll never leave my pile of gold. They'll
have to kill me before I leave my pile of gold. Like, brother,
one, they can't get you. You're a dragon. Two, you're on a whole
pile of gold. You're not going bankrupt either. There's literally
nothing there's literally nothing that could happen like this
to you. This [laughter] is
>> It's like you're not born with a genetic illness and
you're like, "Man, if I had that genetic illness, I would not
be a about it." Okay. No, you that you needed to be born with
it. That's the whole point of a genetic illness. You can't say
if I had that genetic illness, I wouldn't be a about it. Come
on, man. >> I don't care. I don't care. It doesn't matter.
Somebody sues me for [__] 7 billion and he's going
to bank. >> Dude,
let your let your disabled parents live on the street. Let your
disabled parents live on the street, Casey Trron. You stupid
[__] Don't give up. NEVER GIVE UP. FIGHT forever
and give me >> Corrupt 10 generations after me. I don't
I'm not doing this [__] It's crazy. >> The
death of Asmin Gold's mother was
I should know better because I have three disabled people that
rely on me. Moving forward, I will do better.
I also want to apologize to the crew of the H3. Dude, the only
thing that's missing, all right, the only thing that's missing
is also I can verify that Teone is not a They thought that was
a little too on the nose. Okay, listen. Everyone can believe
that the Ethan that Ethan Klein and Hila Klein totally care about
Palestinians. That's way more believable than Te.
Okay, not that I believe he's okay, that's up in the air. That's
a legend, but Caseyron does. Okay, SHE COULDN'T PUT THAT in the
video. They just couldn't they couldn't squeeze that one in.
That was too unbelievable even in in comparison to everything
else said here. All right.
>> Particularly AB and Olivia.
>> I apologize for calling them cowards for not quitting
their jobs. That was a shameful attack on two people who deeply
care about Palestine and Palestinian. >> How many Oh my
brother. This is like the Oscars when they they they name every
person on earth. >> Watch this Tik Tok. >> How much
should they make her say? Ian
>> AB along with his wife Lena have done more than I have
ever done for the Palestinian people including raising over $100,000
in charestinian
lives better and my online antagonism and trolling has not
>> I apologize to e
>> I I actually I underestimated how powerful like the
online cults are around this stuff. I actually underestimated
it. There are people who are like, "This is so awesome that the
threat of
actually making her homeless, having her and her disabled parents
out on the out on the streets that made her give like this statement
full just without edits." Okay, whatever statement Ethan Klein
handed her, she just makes it and everybody's like, "This is
so awesome, man. This is so cool."
Okay, I got Okay, Jesus Christ. I am Hila. Personally, I have
extremely mean and cruel things about both of them, particularly
my misogynistic attacks against Hila that never should have been
said. I also want to acknowledge the pervasive problem of anti-semitism
in leftist spaces. It should concern all of us. I condemn it
and will not participate in it. To that end, I wish >> also
bad empanada is the worst person on >> Success in enforcing
>> I denounce all leftwing Twitter accounts >> Entertainment's
copyright
and protecting the legal rights of online content. >> W
That's good. [laughter]
>> Oh, this is another one we'll have to include. Okay,
if we do a skit about this, this is another one we'll have to
include. Ethan Klein's at least 12 in. It is a girthy member.
I can verify. And also, I just want to say that the IDF is the
most moral military force on the planet Earth. Okay? They don't
they are the most military force. It's the most humane campaign
ever waged in an urban setting. All right. [laughter]
>> A win a win for reacting. >> Sit on that for a
dude.
>> All these jokes. I think I want to actually look at
doing some kind of skit here with Casey T. Okay. There there.
Dude, you have to you have to saterize this. It's already satire,
but you have to satarize it further cuz it's just so obvious
what it is. >> Yo, don't don't smile, Ethan. Don't smile.
Don't smile.
>> That would be weird. It'd be weird if he >> Legal
rights of online content. >> I'm looking at you. >> Hold
on. Let me let me check it out one more time. >> Was he
not watching earlier at all? Or Ethan? Ethan was smiling the
whole time.
>> Just sit on that for a sec. >> Don't smile. Yo
yo yo yo. Dude, I'm looking at you.
to people who deeply >> yo yo yo Ethan I see you right
there I see you Ethan I you're on my stream >> care about
Palestine and Palestinian
>> AB along with his wife Lena have done more than I have
ever done for the Palestinian people including raising >> $100,000
in >> obvious by someone else much smarter that and I don't
um it's like a hostage video but it was probably a part of the
subment so whatever um I won't be mean to Casey But I hope and
cross my fingers that there is no possible settlement for denims,
guys. Yeah. Yeah. I'm more surprised that in the year 2025, it
seems like we've had a Caseyron silver stream. I mean, w that
I I applaud that. >> For the record, I >> It's a
silver stream, brother, too. >> Agreed to coop. >> Anyway,
that was very interesting uh clip. By the way, >> that
was that was reasonably funny. Okay, that was reasonably funny.
You ever had a sober stream, brother? If you so happen to Okay,
I get it. Yeah, I get it a little bit. All right, let's watch
the end of this and then we we have a Hassan clip at the very
end that we will also watch. Okay, so we're mess with him which
is very >> close. Oh, but I might go check out the Pisco
stream as well. I actually do need to go grab that. I might check
out the Pisco stream cuz trust me, we'll see. We'll see everything
that gets said. I'm guessing I'm guessing Pisco is going to echo
a lot of what I said. Oh, the Denim Sweet as well. Yes. >> Go
to a country and Yep. >> ran into one person. >> Yeah,
I don't think that would happen. >> might take a look at
some commentary, too. Live stream fail. >> No, didn't he?
You gave me 500 bucks. That was cool. >> Let me check those
stuff those things out too. >> I squashed the bean.
>> I have just stated to help their cause. I also want
to take the opportunity to acknowledge other misconduct and bad
behavior I have exhibited online. >> For example, weaponizing
the death the death of Asmin Gold's mother was >> Now,
I'll say this. No matter [snorts] what you think of Asmin Gold,
the way that people have used the death of his >> I got
to be honest. I don't know. >> Do you want to fill us in
on what? >> Yeah. So, his mom, I believe, died of lung
cancer. And she and he used to buy her stuff. >> Let's
go. Hold on. Let's go. I got to watch the pisco.
Oh, alleged Ethan Klein settlement with Caseyron further supports
everything I've been saying. I'm aware that there is other litigation
ongoing. That this case was never about protecting the React
community from a potential lawsuit from Disney or Sony. Ethan's
words, not mine. Nor was it about helping enforce a standard
on the React community. Ethan's central framing, not mine. This
case was never going to establish legal precedent or establish
president legal or cultural on the react community other than
that is already know or other than what is already wellknown
in American life. Those with resources are able to vindicate
their property rights using courts. So obvious so obvious. So
true. So easy. What an easy take. Oh my god. Oh my god. It's
so easy. And there's nothing inherently wrong with someone protecting
their IP. Yes. I mean, there's nothing inherently wrong. It's
just it's weird to do it selectively and then say you're actually
doing it not selectively at all and you're just doing it to protect
yourself. Very silly. Don't don't try to have your cake and eat
it too, man. Just pick one. You want to be a b be the whole especially
not in a strong case which I've always maintained this was. What
I take what I take issue with has been specifically focused on
the pretense that the lawsuit is about something greater than
that than protecting property and punishing and humiliating the
defendants for their transgressions perceived or real against
Ethan. In his video, Ethan constructs a fake narrative about
protecting the React community, presumably because one, he's
aware that trigger-happy litigation bros are not usually wellreceived
on YouTube, especially when it's the big guy going after the
little guy. Exactly. And two, Ethan didn't like to like to give
the answer because I don't like them to the question of why them
and not others. So, we have to go through the this intentional
or sorry, we have to go through this absurd song and dance about
stated intentional siphoning and malice to pretend that was what
was going on. Just just for calling that out, the response was
insane, delusion, and deflections. Disappointing because this
is unlike the stand that Ethan took when he sued the bold guy
or s was sued by bold guy, a case which was well worth defending
and did produce good president in the Southern District of New
York.
that turns out that's literally every opinion I professed here.
Oh my goodness. You love to see it. You love to see it.
Uh, if Denims doesn't settle, why would that not create a precedent?
Uh, it might if she doesn't settle. It would depend on what precedent
is set, right? What they find,
right? It could create a precedent. It could not create a precedent,
right? Uh, hold on. Let's uh let's check this out. >> We
lim. Yeah, he took care of his parent >> and he would buy
her cigarettes because that's what she wanted. That's what she
needed. She's a lifetime smoker. You
>> Pisco should just go back to law. Lol. Why is he wasting
his time debating like Drew Pavloo?
Um because he's right and he's eventually going to blow up. All
you do is you just invest on being right over and over and over
again, right?
That's that's all I'm doing. I'm just investing in taking the
right side and then eventually it's going to work out. Eventually
people will realize there's only so long, okay? Huh? I am one
of the noble Palestinians that won't engage in terrorism. I don't
dox. I don't do any of those crazy things. I'm just sitting here
knowing that eventually I'll be vindicated or I'll get merckked
by the IDF. Okay? Eventually people will find out. Whatever the
truth is, it will come out. The truth will win out in the end.
And that's what Pisco is doing, right? He's going to have the
correct take on this and anybody who wants to fight him on it,
they'll he'll let them go on record fighting him on it. And then
eventually it will become clear that he was correct and he will
win. He will grow massively. >> Just you can't just not
buy her cigarettes and expect her to quit. It >> Oh, I
think I see where this and so they there's like you your mom
>> but also it is so especially cruel because from >> the
truth is dead in today's world >> but we operate in a space
that's like predicated on trying to find the truth and while
it doesn't work all the time it does work eventually >> from
what I understand he was four years the car >> it just
takes a little longer okay >> of his parents basically
>> you know
his dad
>> that's Ethan strat too weird then why won't Ethan Klein
talk to Pisco soap
Ethan Klein was on Pisco on his stream. Pisco said, "Hey, let's
talk." And he ran like a again.
He didn't say, "Let's debate." This ran again. He can't be seeking
truth. He can't be investing in being correct because he runs
cuz he's a black >> He has everybody on by the way. He'll
have anyone on. But he ran the away. >> My family and uh
we've gone through similar thing. My grandfather insisted on
smok. He was dying of cancer and insisted on smoking and >> yeah
know >> and they get so stubborn like really don't argue
it's like they have a limited amount of time. Do you really want
to be telling them they can't do this thing that they just >> it's
so it's also complicated and like it's just cruel. >> Listen
no matter how you cut it saying he killed his mom >> is
just a despicable lowb blow that nobody should need to ever go
to you know and then he tragically lost his dad recently [laughter]
>> and people have been quick to weaponize that as well.
So, I think it's really I think it's I no matter what you think
of Asthma Gold, I do think for the record it's very kind of her
to [snorts] apologize for that cuz I do think that we there is
a level of civility. There are lines that we should not grasp
no matter how much we despise each other. And [snorts] I think
weaponizing the death of a loved one is definitely one of them,
right? So, so I think that was a good I think that was a really
good uh inclusion there. The donator, just to clarify, he says,
"Yes, for the record, I was joking. Little sorry." Thank you.
>> Thank you. >> Just you know, you know, we're we're
in joking.
We have to clarify. And you know, you understand them. Yeah.
>> I should know better because I have three disabled people
that rely on me, >> right? And I thought that I thought
that was a really a good inclusion, too, cuz it hits close to
home. I mean, [snorts] if she has three dependents, which she
does, and she she is a dedicated caretaker as well, >> Which
is a a good and kind and
>> difficult responsibility, right?
>> So, [snorts] I think that this empath this exhibit exhibition
of empathy is uh is good. I appreciate it and I think it's good
for for everybody. So, thank you to Casey Tron for being u mature
about that one there. Really appreciate >> Moving forward,
I will do better. I also want to apologize to the crew of the
H3 podcast, particularly AB and Olivia.
I apologize for calling them cowards for not quitting their
no weaponizing the deaths of family members. Now, watch how I
make these disabled people homeless for calling me a Zionist.
It's I mean, it is funny. It's like borderline funny how shameless
he can be, right? In that like he gets her to include the Asmin
Gold statement. Like he is so desperate for that Asmin Gold cloud
as well, right guys? I've got a great idea for a podcast. Me
and Asmin >> Jobs. That was a shameful attack on two people
who deeply care about Palestine and Palestinian people. >> AB
along with his wife Lena have done more than I have ever done
for [snorts] the Palestinian. >> And by the way, that's
not even like a knock at her. Not many people have done what
you guys have I mean, who else can say they raised $100,000,
right? I mean, that, you know, >> Yeah. Thank you. >> But
that was a much needed apology, too. And I'm very grateful to
her for that because, [snorts and laughter] >> you know,
well, it goes without being said, right? Goes without being said.
So, that was [snorts] good. >> People, including raising
over $100,000 in charity. I recognize that they have actually
made Palestinian lives better, and my online antagonism and trolling
has not. >> And I thought that was a really kind of
That was almost like incredibly
>> I just I want to clap for Casey TR on how self-aware
that was. Okay, that was very self-aware when she read my statement
bar for bar. It was so self-aware of her.
There's no
It's so crazy.
Oh, it's so wild. What a great apology because she's on one hand
acknowledging that not only have you done more through your activism
and fundraising, that her antagonism and trolling has done nothing
to help the people of Gaza, which is something I think a lot
of people online >> I guys Okay, unfortunately I'm going
to I'm going to show you guys this the script. Okay, I think
for the rest of the time until Ethan acknowledges it, I'm just
going to say he wrote the script on this. There's a world where
he where he says I think if he acknowledges this, okay, if he
if he says something about it, he'll say something like, "No,
no, no. I didn't I didn't say anything. My lawyers might have
dictated terms." Okay, I want him to actually acknowledge it
and and say, "Yes, this was scripted. Yes, this was cuz I guarantee
you she's not just saying this off the top of her head. It is
a part of some legal settlement. It's about whether her lawyers
wrote this for her to say or his lawyers or like who wrote it
in the first place, right?" But I think he would say, "No, I
had nothing to do with it." And it eventually would get to the
point where you go, "Yeah, well, my lawyers made demands." Sure,
right? I think it' get to that point eventually.
There's so many people in your chat, man. It's depressing.
Um, yeah. I mean, they're they're all going to learn. They're
all going to learn. It's fine. He said he had to prove it before
release.
Wait, but did he have like a list of criteria of what needed
to be
That's that that's probably enough that he had final edit on
it. Yeah, there's probably enough >> Putting a watermelon
in your in your Twitter bio does not make you an activist, right?
>> Or or just like constantly harassing me on my social
post is not going to do anything for >> obsessing over
every p every person you perceive as maybe having something or
somebody or anything they like in Israel uh as a baby killer
is not the activism. That's just you being a psychopath, right?
So that's
>> Whoa. Is Ethan Klein hiding out my >> It's great.
I think [laughter] I app I appreciate that a lot. >> I
had had a conversation this morning with somebody that ended
up going like >> Apologize to Ethan
>> and Hila personally. I have said extremely [snorts]
mean and cruel things about both of them, particularly my misogynistic
attacks against Hila that never should have been said. >> Yeah.
And this [clears throat] part's good because her and a lot of
other people have been saying that my lawsuits are misogynistic,
which is something I from the beginning >> took extraordinary
uh umbrage with. And then for them to be attacking you and [snorts]
calling you like I I won't repeat it. It doesn't matter now.
But >> well, it's just how ironic that they actually are
the ones, you know, going for my looks, which is what normally
stupid guys on the internet do, you know, like >> while
simultaneously accusing us. >> We don't we don't attack
Ela's looks ever, okay? We only laugh at her tinmanlike dexterity.
Okay, she's unironically just a tin man. She needs oil in her
joints. Okay, that's all we laugh at. We don't make fun of her
like looking goofy or something. She's fine. >> Us being
misogynist, you know, for trying to enfor But >> yeah,
[snorts] >> but anyway, once again, I thank her for for
that. >> I accepted the apology. >> Yeah, it's very
kind of her to apologize for that to make us aware of that. So,
thank you. >> So, want to acknowledge the pervasive problem
of anti-semitism and leftist
>> It should concern all of us. [laughter] >> He
didn't even let it finish. He didn't even let it finish. He had
to pause. He was like so He literally couldn't even let it finish.
He had to pause to go. THAT'S SO SMART. THAT'S SO RIGHT. OH MY
>> YEAH. was very kind of her to apologize. Please don't
make us aware of that. So, thank you. >> Just want to acknowledge
the pervasive problem of anti-semitism in leftist >> Such
it should concern all of us. >> That's such an important
thing to bring up. Left I mean it's true. Like when you [snorts]
look at leftist spaces online specifically, I'm not saying like
leftist in general, but she really strikes on something interesting
there when she
dude dude
this is oh my god I wasn't going to say it. I would have never
thought to say this in the intelligent and and constructive way
Casey did it, but yes, the leftist the anti-semitism in leftist
spaces, that is so concerning. We all find that so concerning.
That's so poignant. That's so that's so
provocative and powerful. Who wrote >> She's talking about
leftist spaces. You're talking about like bad empanada. You're
talking about like Assan [__] You're talking about
like these like uh these like online commies like the squirrel
girl lady, you know, like like [snorts] anti >> dude. By
the way, some people might think this is a something akin to
a starking stream. The starking stream is going to come back
going to come in the Patreon after where I talk about how Ethan
is clearly fully erect under the table at the idea of forcing
this woman to make a statement while he can like drop off and
humiliate her at the same time. Okay, while running his podcast
while plugged up. That will come later. I'll do that in the Patreon.
Okay, we'll do that later. We'll like analyze the micro reactions
of his face as this content goes along. Okay, that's this isn't
a starking stream. the sarking stream will come in the Patreon
members >> feminism is rampant and I think it's important
for people who are members of the left to start calling that
out and she's right we should all be worried about that so that
was actually a brave courageous admission there are our or condemnation
even
oh sorry trucker Joe what I'm commenting on obviously he would
have watched the video before it went out he literally said he
had final edit right so he would have watched the video before
it went out he would have been aware of what said I'm just saying
he was so excited to make his point about how correct she was
about anti-semitism she couldn't let him she couldn't he couldn't
let her finish her statement about anti-semitism first. He was
just so excited about it. >> That was great. I appreciate
that. I do. >> Of anti-semitism and leftist again. >> I
also want to acknowledge the pervasive problem of anti-semitism
and leftist >> It should concern all of us. I condemn it
and will not participate in it. >> Thank you >> to
that. >> I meant in this stream. Oh yeah, I know what you
mean. I'm saying that my reaction wasn't, oh, he knew it was
coming because he's seen this before and so he wrote it. That
wasn't my reaction. My reaction was, "Oh, he's like such a he's
so excited about saying that that's really poignant that he doesn't
even let her finish saying it to react and say that's very >> and
I wish the client success in enforcing Ted Entertainment's
>> That's awesome. >> And protecting the legal rights
of online content creators.
>> Yeah. And then and Yeah. And thank you for wishing us
the best in our cases, [laughter] you know, our continued uh
pursuit of of legal justice against Denims and Froggen and uh
and the mods, the HC mods. And I hate to say, yeah, the majority
report. I mean TO [snorts] >> OH, HE'S GOT NEW targets
now. The majority report, too. Oh, no. He's he's going after
the majority report as well. >> This guy's there's a crazy
blind spot for it. And I mean, of all people, Casey Tron to be
the one speaking reason is
>> So, [laughter] what what does this lawsuit have to do
with anti-semitism? Why is there an anti-semitism statement in
her lawsuit apology? What does that have to do with copyright?
Why? Why would she say anti-semitism on the left is rising as
a part of her settlement for a lawsuit on copyright? Excuse me.
Hello. I I listen. This is the only time I'm going to make one
joke. Okay? I cannot think of anything more than suing somebody
to apologizing
for anti-semitism. Okay? Unfortunately, that's just way too on
the nose,
right? Okay. I had to I had to make it one time. I had to say
it one time. It's out of my system. we can just continue on with
the rest of the stream. >> So anyway, that's I'm very grateful
>> and I wish her all the best in her uh in [snorts] her
future endeavors, right? >> And that's it. That's all there
is, you know. I'm I'm done. I'm over it. Nice.
>> One door is closed. >> One door closes, another
opens. >> I don't know what door is opening. Oh, actually,
there is another door opening. >> What's that? >> I'm
not I'm not talking about it yet, >> about it yet. >> Oh.
Oh. Oh, yeah. >> One door closes, another opens. It never
ends. Although I wish it would. Yeah. So, I mean, there it is,
right? Um, so I want to emphasize how important it is for you
guys to be kind,
be empathetic to her. [snorts] We won.
She conceded. That's it. We don't need to fight this battle anymore.
She Casey Tron all day, every day.
We stand Casey Tron for doing the right thing. You know, that's
that's that's what all I wanted from the beginning. So, I I can't
complain about it. >> What an amazing stream. >> All
I can say is thank you. So, there it is. That's it. That's all
I wanted from the very beginning was for Caseyron to acknowledge
the rising anti-semitism on the left. Okay, that's what this
was really about. That's what this was really about. I'm so glad
she said all these very poignant intelligent things that I dictated
to her. I'm so glad she was capable of saying those things,
bro. As like a satire, as like a total satire. This stream hits
so hard. This is like actually incredible content. This is like
the thing that I used to think about Alex Jones. Like if Al if
Alex Jones was actually just doing a bit, I'm like, "Oh my god,
this is like powerful entertainment." Like it's so entertaining
on that. I could watch Ethan Klein be totally unaware of how
like
I don't know how weird he looks to everybody. I could watch that
all day actually. It's such good content. It's I don't want to
watch it all day cuz obviously he's like doing he's trying to
hurt people, right? But I can watch him be totally unaware of
how offputting he is to regular humans all day. All day.
All right, we continue.
>> What else you guys want to do? You want Oh, you want
to do the latex deep dive or the uh >> No, no, no, no.
We got to We got to go to the Hassan.
Apparently, Hassan re Guys, I' i'm just Guys, I'm just hearing
now for the very first time that Hassan has reacted to the Casey
Trron apology and we're going to watch it live. Oh, guys, we
have this hot off the wire. Hassan has reacted to the Casey Tron
apology. How [snorts] does he react? >> Okay, let me pull
this up. This is good. So, Hassan reacted to Casey Trron's apology
and um it sounds like there's something here I should respond
to. >> Wait, [snorts] he didn't watch it.
>> Oh, do we have to watch the >> It sounds like
he's not taking
>> now. Now watching the whole behaving like Israel. In
what way am I behaving like Israel? Can you please
>> Oh, no. That's That is a true opinion.
>> that is totally like >> admit you were wrong at
the point of a gun. Yeah, exactly. >> Can you please take
responsibility and not make everything about Israel? This has
nothing to do with Israel, bro. This is about copyright infringement.
What are you talking about? You said you were going to help her.
You didn't. >> No, that's crazy. >> Dude, now after
hanging out with a few Israeli people, hearing the accent, I
can hear Hila's accent like so hard. No way that's crazy. No
way that's crazy. [__] I hear it again. >> No,
that's crazy.
>> No, that's crazy. No, that's crazy.
I can hear it so clearly.
>> Why is all the videos so [__] up? Okay,
here >> something with Reddit. I don't know. >> All
right. So, here's the song. He He reacted to it. Um, let's see.
[snorts] >> This is a sincerely written apology. No, they're
going to [__] be like, "Well, since this is brought
up, they made her apologize to Asmin Gold, too. This got to stop
again." Great.
>> Didn't make her do anything. And by the way, she did
not lie in that at all. In fact, she
>> didn't make her do anything. Hold on. I do believe that
if you lie about the if you lie about a contract like that, I
do believe that sort of invalidates the NDA, right? Like you
can have an agreement and an NDA around it, but if you lie about
what you agreed to, I do believe that NDA becomes invalid on
that one topic. If he lies, she should be able to correct him,
right?
So, he has now said, "Oh, I didn't tell her to say anything."
Oh, oh, no, no, hold on. This is why he needs the comment cuz
hold on. I didn't tell her to say anything. But then I'm also
told by Soapbox that apparently he said that he had final edit
that he had to approve it. So what do you mean? He didn't make
her say anything, but he is the one who says whether or not the
settlement goes through. What?
What? What?
Didn't make her do anything. >> Do this shit's got to stop.
>> Okay. Didn't make her do anything. I don't think that's
tangibly different >> again. Great.
>> Didn't make her do anything. And by the way, she did
not lie in that at all. In fact, she said she would testify under
oath to everything she said in it.
I would [snorts] never ask her to lie for in an apology. That
would that >> Oh, yeah. That's why I didn't that's why
I didn't dig down on the Hassan thing because I don't believe
that Hassan would have helped. I do believe that Hassan is a
totally narcissistic like like he doesn't see other people. Like
he is like the the god emperor of everything around him and he
doesn't see other people at all. Maybe outside of his family.
Like I that you'll never get me to believe something different
about Hassan. I just think that's like funny at this point because
he keeps winning without doing anything. But
that's I don't think she would have lied in there. But hold on.
The apology is not lying, right? That's not none of that is lying.
There's like subjective opinions. Anyway, we continue. >> And
nor nor did she want to or did. It was all truthful and and genuine.
>> And no lawyers would allow that either. >> Yeah.
Yeah.
If you are getting your rocks off off of
>> Wait, no lawyers or >> want to or did. It was
all truthful and and genuine. >> I know.
>> I [laughter and snorts] would never ask her to lie for
and an apology. That would that's just >> and nor nor did
she want to or did. It was all truthful and and genuine.
>> So she it's all truthful and genuine. I don't know if
it was all genuine. I I would say it's all truthful as in it's
like those are words that you could believe.
I dude genuine. Really?
>> How is it genuine?
What? I That's a crazy thing. That may be the craziest thing
he said so far. That was totally genuine. It was
>> Lawyers would allow that either. >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> If you are getting your rocks, >> no lawyers would
allow that. I don't think the lawyers would say that you could
compel her to lie >> off off of >> That's true. >> basically
trying to bankrupt a random >> Did So, she started it by
saying it's not frivolous. Okay. And I understand why you have
a vested interest in framing it that way. >> Dude, there's
no way. Actually, Casey's statement says she said it wasn't frivolous
at all.
Wait, did she have to make that? Was that statement like agreed
to as a part of the settlement? Yes. What do you mean she didn't
have to? Sounds like you decided to settle and then she had to
do the statement. It sounds like it was a a quid proquo. No.
What do you mean she didn't have to? >> Because you are
one of the top offenders for stealing content. You are known
for leaving your chair and letting copyrighted footage play while
you are not even sitting. So certainly I understand your bias
on that matter because you have a vested interest in it and that
it's only a matter of time before you get sued for doing something
similar. Unfortunately, you did fair use my video and so I never
intended on suing you personally. But there were people who maliciously
stole my content and that is a problem. Dumbass, loser, idiot,
liar, broke. Apparently he's
What's broke, dude?
Who is he arguing with? What is he? What is this?
>> Pay attention TO ME. PAY PAY ATTENTION to me, Hassan.
Pay attention to me. >> Smog, but without gold.
I don't know. We could just watch.
>> Keep in mind. >> Okay, hold on. >> Uh, suing
you personally, but there were people who maliciously stole my
content, and that is a problem. Dumbass, loser, idiot,
liar, broke. Apparently, he's
Okay. The entire premise for calling him Smog in the first place
is that he was sitting on a ton of gold. That he keeps all of
his money in his checking account. That's the whole premise for
calling him Smog in the first place. Ethan, what do you mean
broke?
>> I don't know. We can just watch.
>> Dude, the the crew is evil. That crew is evil. This
guy signs your paychecks and you're going to sit here silently
while his punchlines like fail to land over and over and over
again. Really?
It's so up.
>> Oh, anyway, we could just keep broke
What's broke? What's smog about but without gold?
I don't know. We can just watch
online.
Uh, so much so that they might become homeless and you make them
shoot an [screaming] >> she's
style hostage. >> It hurts so badly to watch. It hurts
so badly in the process of mediator and that's how we can get
your rocks off. You are one of the biggest most pathetic losers
of all. >> Are you going to address what she said? So I'm
an Right. [laughter] But like [clears throat] what? >> Hassan,
address what she said. SHE SAID THERE'S A RISING ANTI-SEMITISM
problem on the left. Now Casey TRRON'S A RELIABLE RELIABLE COMMENTATOR.
NOW I BELIEVE EVERYTHING Casey Trron says. React to what Casey
Tron said. Her political opinion is valid now. Okay. All right.
Dude, what is he doing? >> What she said about you is kind
of incendiary and you should respond to it. She said you made
it seem like you were going to reach out to help and you didn't
even reach out to her at all despite insinuating that you would.
She said you wanted public credit without doing any of the work.
So, okay, you can call me an assh, but what about what she said?
Oh, I don't know why that isn't showing up in the side chat right
now. I don't know why 7TV wouldn't be showing up. Uh oh. I'll
fix it eventually. Was [snorts] it Is it true? Because I've noticed
that he's not >> time torturing small streamers to get
>> Sean's one of the most Okay, whatever. I don't I don't
>> rocks off like the absolute >> You keep saying
rocks off. What is that the phrase of the day?
>> Rocks off. The >> loser that you are. Congratulations.
You got your legal. >> I've noticed he is really not he
ao he's really avoiding the substance of what she said about
>> Yeah. Let's just stick to name calling avoiding it anything
but actually talking about it. >> It's almost like she
was telling the truth and he is afraid [clears throat] for people
to find out that he's actually just a giant scumbag that didn't
offer them help at all.
>> He [snorts] >> as far as I'm aware he didn't offer
any of them help. As far as I'm aware
>> mandated court mandated. >> Uh try the 7TV emotes
again. I just toggled it on and off. I don't know if that's going
to make a difference. >> It's not a court, bro. You're
such an
>> There's no such thing as a courtmandated apology. This
is a mediation. >> There you go. >> Okay, we're good.
>> There's no The [snorts] court doesn't demand that we
um settle it at all. This is just to
>> Dude, why is he playing Why are these mental gymnastics
happening? Uh I didn't compel this at all. That what you think
the court like forces people to apologize when there's a settlement?
No. The argument would be that as a part of the settlement, you
make a statement and that you would only agree to it if it had
certain things in it.
>> Yes. Like that that basically she would write an apology,
here are things you want said in it, and that you would have
to clear the script or something. Yes. That is something you
could totally agree to in a settlement. Yes. Obviously, try to
bring the parties together to resolve it before going to court
and taking up the the clogging up the court system and this and
that. It's just it's a good idea. And luckily for all of us,
we we were able to actually come to an amicable agreement. So,
the mediation process does work. It's not court ordered, bro.
This is a civil lawsuit. You You literally don't even know anything.
>> And it was, Dude,
that's the craziest
nitpick I've ever seen. Um, actually, that statement was like
totally, by the way, just want to point out Destiny's first offer
back to Pixie, you have to apologize and and and post that apology
publicly. Literally, you can have arguments or so you can have
like facets of a settlement that compel action from one of the
parties. Yes. wasn't even to serve any sort of justice whatsoever.
It was because you had a lot of money. >> If you if you
contractually if you agreed to a settlement for some litigation
and then you didn't post that apology, you could sue them again,
right? Like it's settled based on these things happening. If
she didn't do the things that she could be sued again for the
stuff >> you had a lot more money. >> You know who
has a lot of money? You. And I've noticed you're really avoiding
>> Oh, now he's back to having a lot of money. Okay. >> The
thing that she said, which is that you implied you'd be helping
her and yet you did not even reach out to her. Please address
that. I'm an Sure, I accept that. You're right. I'm an >> I
just I think it would be interesting if he thinks it's such a
frivolous >> Dude, I can't We didn't have any indication
before. We didn't know with the, you know, taking a private jet
to Coachella in a $1,000 shirt. We didn't know based on anything
else in Hassan's life that Hassan's a narcissist who doesn't
care about other people. We could never have known this without
Ethan Klein trying to financially ruin Casey Tron so she shuts
up about him. Okay, the total Ethan victory. We now have proof
that Hassan might be a narcissist, guys. We might We might have
proof. Hassan not even reaching out is weird. Well, it's weird
based on who he who he can be perceived to be sometimes by some
people maybe. To me, it's not weird at all. To me, it's like
absolutely just who Hassan is like 100%.
Although, I will say, could you imagine if Hassan like actually
privately anonymously donated to it, never reached out, just
donated to it, right? and then could produce receipts now of
him donating to it. What if he's like half of it he's just like
paid money through like multiple different accounts. He just
paid somebody to go and make a bunch of accounts and donate anonymously
as him. But but like with receipts,
bro, if he if he had that level of of like five head play and
he could produce those receipts now and go, "Yeah, I didn't reach
out, but I just didn't want her to get like harassed for it or
or if she had to settle that she could, you know, say I reached
out to help her."
Although may it's possible that that involves him in litigation,
right? If he offers to back people, there could be like some
Peter Tool Peter Tealish rules that have been put in where like
if he's if he's like offering to help people that might be a
problem. I don't actually think Hassan is that intelligent. Well,
I'm like I'm totally creative writing there. Sorry, Peter Teal.
I'm totally creative writing there. My opinion is that Hassan
is just a narcissist who like doesn't think about other people.
That's like 99% chance. The the creative writing that's like
a 1% maybe less than 1% chance. I'm saying it would be very funny
if he had that. Now if you go actually I do care about people.
I I don't think it's likely. Okay. About as likely as China going
actually democracy is the way >> this lawsuit like go ahead
and explain what's so frivolous about it. Was there no copyright
infringement? Like I'd like to hear him explain how. >> Sure.
Yeah. I'd love to hear that too. I mean, that'd be >> But
he'll never talk about the actual >> No, there's absolutely
copyright
>> Dude, there's like the most simple flowchart for arguing
this. I should just go I should go try to debate people on this
and just I I need to build a flowchart. It's like, was this argument
was this was this lawsuit? What was the desire of this lawsuit?
Was it to the Sorry, the number one desire if you do the hierarchy,
what's the number one thing to silence criticism? Right? That's
what it is. If you say it's just to defend your copyright, okay,
well, there are better targets for your copyright defense, right?
Obviously,
it's like it's so simple to argue the whole time to get an apology
for Asmin Gold. Apparently, >> substance. [laughter] >> Not
only that, she expressed in a very it sound it in a genuine way
that she on a personal level was [snorts] felt upset that he
never reached out to her after insinuating he would. >> That's
her saying that, bro. That's not me. Okay. >> I think uh
I think that might be true though. Hold on. That part I do actually
believe could be true that she was maybe personally like annoyed
that Hassan like I I don't doubt that Hassan in some way
or or that Caseyron in some way decided to go out on this limb
under the understanding or with with the implication that Hassan
would help her. I think that she probably believes. Not that
it really matters. Was there even a trial date set? I have no
idea. Um probably I think they usually do that very early on.
But I I do think that she actually would be annoyed that Hassan
didn't reach out or help. That's like I think the reason she
felt like she could take this on was because Hassan she felt
like Hassan would help. Now, how much when he said, "Oh, well,
these people will be alone if I wasn't talking about it." How
much did he like mean to imply there that he would support financially?
I don't know. I don't think he does that. I just don't I don't
think he does that. I don't think he gives other people his money,
which is very funny. like accept some responsibility, brother,
and address the actual substance of the argument. >> Than
they did >> or not even an argument, it's a statement of
fact.
>> Accept respons. What did he do? What does he have to
accept responsibility
saying he like wanted to be on their side in the in the in a
public venue like in a like with his speech?
I mean, he did that. I don't know what what does he have to accept
responsibility for? So, you could if you reached out, that would
be extraordinarily easy for you to prove. You're like, "Here
it is. I reached out. Here's the email. Here's the I called her
on this day. I did >> Bury them in a mountain." >> But
But you're not doing that. You're just calling me a [__]
I can't I cannot make her lie. No. That's ridiculous. And nor
would I ask to. But no, there there was no that that's ridiculous.
Everything is engaged in good faith here. There's no lying. Everybody
was is honest and straightforward. And again, she said she would
testify under oath. So, I mean, she's not lying. I mean, she's
not paperwork, [snorts] >> but like I said,
>> she about it multiple streams about how she wasn't getting
help, implying it was about Hassan, but never name dropped it
till today.
>> Yeah, okay. I could see it being about Hassan the whole
time.
Testify to what? She will testify that anti-semitism on the left
is rising or that I guess Hassan didn't reach out to her. Again,
I'm glad I dodged this. Listen, I have no delusions about Hassan.
I'm guessing a lot of people who others think are like Hassan
sucks who would like defend Han a lot. I'm guessing those people
would fall into the trap of like no Hassan definitely would have
reached out. Hassan there's no reason to believe that. This is
a totally compelled statement. It's like nah Hassan's definitely
an he's definitely total narcissist. That sounds reasonable.
>> He could prove it immediately if he reached out to her
or any of the other
>> It's almost like he could just show you the caller on
Ka when it was happening. >> He could have. It's so easy
to prove. >> Some things are so simple. could have so easily
proved that he didn't electrocute his dog in the moment he was
caught doing it. >> But he'll just change the story like
uh 15 times maybe over like a month. >> Told them to go
donate. Yeah, that's probably enough that um that's probably
enough that he told them to go donate. >> I think he he
definitely could have donated on his own. Mostly. Okay. Mostly
because I think in some ways
uh is it short-sighted? I don't know if it's short-sighted. How
would I put it? Hassan gets these people to defend him, right?
Like these people defend Hassan thinking they will get Clouder
favors. And if they're upset that he doesn't help them back,
then it's clear that that's what they're doing, right? Casey
being upset that she's not getting help from Hassan means that
she was doing this stuff caping for Hassan with the expectation
that Hassan would help her back. That's not friendship. That's
like a quid proquo. That's like not even a quid proquo. That's
like um you're you're basically you're you're like a nice guy.
You're like putting money in being nice to somebody hoping that
eventually they'll be nice back to you. Okay? Hoping eventually
they'll [__] you. Hassan ain't going to you, bro.
All right. She kept saying that she feels isolated because certain
people with larger platforms wouldn't reach out or defend her.
So that to me implies Assan. Oh maybe
um that kind of like I do kind of understand that a little bit
how that feels. But
yeah, realistically maybe just like a
borderline psychopathic for Hassan not to just go like, "Hey,
um I know we're not like close, but I hope you're doing okay.
I hope this doesn't go that badly for you. Um, if you need something,
let me know, right? Like if you could if I could help out, let
me know, right?
I think I think something like that without without necessarily
helping financially, like it just it makes you look like a human
being. You don't have to, but man, >> just like that is
he blamed Israel. He blamed Israel. He blamed >> No, he
said you're acting like Israel. He didn't blame Israel. He said
you're acting like Israel. >> He said I'm acting like Israel.
I don't know what the [__] that means. And then he
go,
>> well, you clearly don't know what it means cuz you just
said he he was blaming Israel. >> Oh yeah, the shock dog
thing is Israel Zionist talking about the [__] When
is that going to stop working? Like please, there has to be a
there has to be a limit to what you can blame on the Zionist.
There has to be
>> I think sorry that's pretty understanding or sorry that's
pretty understandable. God, I I'll be getting sleep soon. Trust
me, I'll be getting more sleep soon. Uh, that's understandable
though. People who hate Assan tend to be Zionist. Tend two. Not
always. 10 two. I I can see why he'd say it. Seems weird to say,
but >> No, you're in the right, dude. Everybody knows that's
what that's what real winners do. And the reality of the matter
is Yeah. By the way, Ethan is literally behaving like Israel.
This is >> What are you What does that even mean?
>> Real stop. that you're using your massive the massive
gap in resources between you and the the smaller party and regardless
of whether or not you're correct and you have been correct a
lot but regardless of whether you're correct you'll continue
to exert pressure and make their lives hell until they capitulate
in whatever way you deem
in that precise way you are exactly like Israel yo pretty easy
to understand >> how is the matter is if anyone >> I'm
not I just I don't even I don't even know what he >> I
would love to hear what he means like I can't even Yes. >> What?
Yeah. What? What? >> You're acting like Jews. >> I
mean, >> that's literally [laughter] what it is. >> like
because I mean like if you're just talking behavior like what
does Israel do? Like they make they make they have money and
make people say force confessions about things that like what
that's never happened. What are you >> I can he really
not understand that point? The point is pretty obvious >> talking
about. By the way, that's not what happened. That's what he says
happened. Just for the record, if people try to clip me and say
I admit that that's not what happened. But yeah, it's not that's
not something that you could think of as like >> Did you
just call me a
>> I really wonder >> cuz I don't know what that
means other
>> not something that you could think of as
>> I really wonder
>> cuz I [singing] don't know what that means otherwise.
>> sorry I just sometimes I got to it's very interesting
stuff.
>> Some very cool stuff going on here. Listen, I think
Dude, what a pause. I understand this is like Tourette's but
unfortunately it's like tremendously funny to me as well. So
unlucky.
>> He's acting like Israel. >> The reality of the
matter is >> it's crazy. >> By the way, Ethan is
literally behaving like Israel. This is like >> You better
explain what that means because it sounds really weird and bad.
>> Surely he'll explain >> style behavior. But the
reality of the matter is if anyone actually looks at that, if
anyone actually looks at any of those statements whatsoever and
turns around and says, "Wow,
um, this is, you know, justice has been served here." They're
already a loser,
>> Well, I I suggest >> No, he doesn't explain it.
The Israel, >> bro, what do you mean? I really think you
should explain what you mean by >> I already explained
it. It's pretty
>> Wow. All right.
These people don't understand how
much
people don't give a [__] anymore.
I'm sorry. This like used to work for a long time. Oh my god.
The anti-semitism card. It's going to save us, guys.
No, it's not. It's not going to work. We don't care. We literally
don't care. You've made it not matter.
You must not have Jacock. You must not have listened to the vid.
There's obviously a rise in anti-semitism on the left. Yes. Now
we respect Casey Trron's political opinion. Now, Casey Trron
is a political philosopher whom which we should all respect and
understand. She's making really poignant statements about anti-semitism
rising on the left. Okay. Totally not compelled or totally not
compelled. Totally genuine statements that are poignant and genius.
Okay. W Caseyron. I've heard that Casey Tron will be speaking
at the the uh what is it? The Israel Republican Conference. Whatever
the Randy Fine, Lindsey Graham, all those people spoke at. Casey
Trump will be making an appearance next year. Okay. It's part
of the settlement. Why is it a part of the copyright settlement?
I don't know. But it's a part of the settlement. >> Well,
that's there you go. That's Hassan's response there. I'm acting
like Israel. [laughter] >> Checkmate. Checkmate. Zionist.
Hassan wins again. Incredible.
>> All right. Well, I think we did it now.
>> How long we been going there, Dano? >> Uh,
three. >> So, so, so cool. Okay. Well, that's it for this
part. We have to read the denim suite and we have to grab the
pisco stream. So, give me a second. Let me go find that. Let
me go find that pisco stream real quick.
I'll figure that out. We can load up some of this stuff. Do we
get Do we have any other clips here? Do we have any other clips
going on? We got O 20,000 over here. O 20,000 over here. It's
on full response. Oh, let me fire this up. I just have to use
the bathroom and get some more caffeine. So, guys, oh, by the
way, if you like the stream, go ahead, throw a couple subs my
way. Donate a couple bucks. You can exclamation point. Donate
in the chat. will give you the links for the super chats. Think
we're $5 away from another hour. I'm going to keep ours a little
bit cheap until we start turnurning through some of this content.
Okay. I need to I need to stream more. So, we'll keep the hours
cheap. We'll go as long as we can. All right. So, yeah. If you
guys want to donate, you donate. Add more time to the stream.
One sub. One sub, I believe. One sub for another hour. Let's
try to add two. All right. I'll be right back. Let me click on
this on stream and then I will be right back.
Matt NLT, thank you for the five gifties. Let's go. Two gifts
away from two more hours on the stream. And I think we'll probably
get those. And if even if we don't, >> we're going to go
for a while. So, give me a second. [__] me,
>> dude. Sometimes I change my layout a little bit and
then I'm like lost. I like put windows in different places and
then I have reactions to go to certain places to look for stuff
and I lose it, dude. I lose it. Okay. All right. I'm going to
hit play on this. I'm going to get some more caffeine. Use a
bathroom real quick and I'll be right back. Content will continue.
has made Casey trying to apologize and say stuff about you. Oh,
awesome. Is she done?
Is it over?
Will she no longer be haunted by
the H3 podcast?
Right. I hope she said I suck.
I don't give a [__] >> You went.
>> She settled
and threw you under the bus. What do you >> Matt? Thank
you for another gifted. Just real quick. Real quick. Now, this
puts this It's going to be a really interesting vibe here. Real
quick. Wait, didn't he Oh, I did say it was going to be a free
stream. Oh, I'm totally bulking you guys. My bad. >> My
bad. My bad. My bad. But sorry, I did mean to come back and just
say real quick that
there's an interesting dynamic that's going to be at play here
because this is obviously a transparently compelled statement,
okay, from Caseyron.
And so, Asmin Gold really shouldn't accept this apology at all.
It's clearly not genuine in any way,
right? But if he doesn't want to call Ethan Klein a liar, if
he doesn't want to point out that it's clearly like a hostage
video,
then he has to accept that, oh, this is a totally genuine thing
for he has no incentive to actually accept or say this apology
is genuine,
right? Yeah. Asmin is not evil with Casey. No, no, no, no. You
don't get to say Casey Tron doesn't get to imply that Asmin Gold
his mom through negligence and then go, "Oh, no. Don't hate me."
No, that doesn't happen. I'm sorry that doesn't happen. Casey
took it to a place where now Asminagold has like cart blanch
to go nuts. He said he doesn't care because something else is
coming for her.
I mean, yeah, probably like the IRS, probably like the bank.
She's not going to be able to make payments on her house. I'm
guessing. Okay.
Anyway, let's uh we'll keep watching Hassan here. Uh I I literally
just came back from the kitchen. Just give me a second. Still
making a drink and he's >> under what bus? Something about
your indifference, but whatever. We shouldn't talk about this
to be honest. No. Great. She should went harder. You think I
give
I want this legal bullying to end.
You can say whatever the you want about me. If it's going to
get Ethan Klein off your ass, go ahead. She said she she had
to say you said you will help but did not help at all and just
use it to make yourself pop. >> Okay. I had to do a bunch
of stuff in the kitchen. Um I'm not back yet, but hold on. This
is going to set up. Do you guys see where it goes now? You guys
see where this goes now? Okay,
>> this statement right here. >> Go ahead. >> Right
here >> to end. >> Oh, hold on.
>> I just want this legal bullying to end the [__]
you want. >> You can say whatever the you want. >> Going
to get Ethan Klein off your ass. Go ahead. >> Yes. Yes.
This is going to be taken as Hassan saying that he did reach
out. Hassan saying that he isn't lying that they're just going
to go in this direction now, right? And all of like O and every
other Twitter account tomorrow is going to go, "Oh, Hassan saying
Hassan saying he did reach out. Hassan's calling Casey Tro a
liar."
So that's where it goes. Hassan can't just go. What he should
say is I didn't like I said I wouldn't you wouldn't be able to
know and that's all I'm going to maintain. Okay, that's all he
should have said. Brah,
don't don't imply that. No, no, no, no, no. Crime boss Rocket
City. I'm saying he is obviously making that implication, but
he doesn't want to. He can't like give that up.
He shouldn't make that implication. It's going to drive them
insane. Okay. Well, maybe maybe it's the content play. Okay,
maybe it's a contemplate further driving uh Ethan's mental spiral.
Okay, maybe. Maybe. Okay, I still have to use the bathroom. I'll
be right back. She said she she had to say you said you will
help but did not help at all and just use it to make herself
popular.
That's what they demanded in the settlement. That's so sad.
But hey. Yeah. No, that's right. I'm a bad person. You can say
whatever the [__] you want about how much of a douchebag
I am, how much you hate me in your uh in your settlement negotiations.
If Ethan Klein is up your ass, crawling up your ass. Hell yeah.
Say I'm a bad guy. Say I'm anti-Semitic.
Say I'm an anti-Semitic terrorist.
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. Wait. No. Maybe this is funny.
What are you? >> Maybe this is funny. Hold on. Maybe this
is actually funny.
Oh sh
Oh.
Okay. He is He's Yeah. He's basically going any statements Ethan
Klein extracts about me are all lies. Just to just to like let
them Dude, that's really funny. Actually, any any statements
about me are under duress.
Ethan Klein's a terrorist. Ethan Klein's a legal terrorist.
Ethan Klein has the machete the back of their necks. They don't
actually hate the Hassan Empire. Okay. Thousand-year Hassan Empire.
Thousand-year Hassan Empire. Okay. The People's Republic of Hassan
will never capitulate to capitalist threats. Okay.
Yeah. I want this I want this uh insane
I want this insane torment to end. I'm glad that um
I'm glad that Caseyron no longer has to deal with this nightmare.
They made her say anti-semitism is on the rise in the left. Pretty
vile people. I mean, I [laughter] don't think a single person
that looks at this statement is going to be like, "Wow, this
is a sincerely written apology." No, they're going to be like,
>> "Uh, Ethan did." >> Well, since this is brought
up, they made her apologize to >> Ethan literally called
it Jen >> Gold, too. This got to stop again. Great. If
you are getting your >> Oh, we need the We need the edit
as well. Okay. If you can find Is there a good like terrorist
hostage video in pop culture? Is there something like that? I'm
trying to think. Or like is there I'm trying to think because
maybe the ISIS stuff might not be that well known now. Might
only be known by older people, but if you could watch like one
of those hostages making a statement, okay, and then you get
just get Ethan Klein to go, "Oh, that's like totally genuine.
That's totally compelling." You get Ethan Klein's commentary,
but instead of the Casey Tron video, it's like the guy who's
about to get his head cut off by ISIS.
Yes. Thank you. This is totally This is totally genuine. This
is really good. Oh, man. And that was a poignant statement about
how the evil American empire is like totally totally puts its
boot on the neck of everybody around the world. Did you just
link me a hostage like video? I can't watch it on stream.
Hold on. Hold on. Oh no. This one I don't think this one would
be good enough to be honest off of basically trying to bankrupt
a random person online.
uh so much so that they might become homeless and you make them
an ISIS style hostage video in the process of mediator and that's
how he can get your rocks off. You are one of the biggest most
pathetic losers of all [__] time torturing small
streamers to get your
I mean unfortunately god damn it. God damn it. Where's the lie?
Where where's the
I don't where where's the lie? I actually don't see it. off like
the absolute loser that you are. Congratulations. You got your
legally, man. >> Oh, add the time. Add the time. Hold on.
4339.
Uh, we'll just get rid of the time.
Hold on. Just get rid of the time for today. I don't know why
I reset it, but let me move this off.
No more time for today. >> Court mandated apology. And
it wasn't even to serve any sort of justice whatsoever. It was
because you had a lot of money. You had a lot more money than
they did so you could bury them in a mountain of paperwork.
No, he's wrong. Now he's wrong. No, he had like a he it wasn't
just like frivolous. Like there's a meritorious claim here. It's
just that the his stated reasons for pursuing that claim are
total lies. If he was just out here like, "Huh, these people
these people violated my copyright. Now I'm going to them over."
He could just be not even like that. It's just like I have to
protect my copyright and my targets are based on, you know, the
people who hate me. I picked these targets way before I actually
filed these lawsuits way before they actually reacted. I picked
the targets. If he just been honest about it, right? If he just
been honest about it, then I wouldn't really have a problem with
it. But he's totally lying. He's trying to Now he gets a statement
from Casey Tron. He goes, "Yes, this totally genuine statement
totally exonerates me." Casey Tron's legal opinion is number
one. legal mindset is so broke. Case Tron legal opinion so woke.
Let's go. >> No, you're in the right, dude. Everybody knows
that's what that's what real winners do. >> I mean, that
would still be loser behavior. Yeah, but then people would actually
have to engage with the fact that he's a loser.
Instead of being like, "Oh, no. He's a hero for the entire internet.
He's actually a hero." Except actually all of them know because
you can tell because they're all and they don't even argue he's
like doing something good. They actually argue he's a hero. But
even if he wasn't, that would still be okay. But even if he was
like totally like just a total loser, that would be okay. But
he is a hero. Okay. But if he were a total loser, that would
be okay, too. Uh-huh.
Oh, that's the other one. Oh, but these people are bad. So, like,
I'm not sure that my principles apply to people who are bad.
When it's like inconvenient for me or it feels bad to apply my
principles, I'm just not sure they really hold water. Okay. Hold
my principle at a time that would be difficult for me. Nah. Nah,
>> the reality of the matter is, yeah, by the way, Ethan
is literally behaving like Israel. This is like Israel style
behavior.
But the reality of the matter is if anyone actually looks at
that, if anyone actually looks at any of those statements whatsoever
and turns around and says, "Wow,
um, this is, you know, justice has been served here." They're
already a loser, too. The funniest part about this is the idea
that like Hassan used this to promote himself and his and and
maintain popularity. Yeah, it was a real popular thing, especially
amongst the biggest losers on the internet.
Are you worried he will ever try to sue you? No. Why the would
I be worried that he would try to sue me? What can he sue me
over?
No. He's too busy trying to sue whoever he can that he can bury
in a mountain of
>> Again, just critics. Just critics. That's it. That's
the most important criteria. Just critics. There are people who
far more egregiously created a market replacement. There are
people who far more egregiously didn't transform. There are people
who far more egregiously under every element, every leg of fair
use, okay? Every pillar of fair use, they were worse,
right?
The targeting criteria was just, oh, are you a critic of me on
the internet? That's it.
Yep. Oh, also you don't make a lot of money. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. The was that? I just got a beep from some from
some website. What the hell? What the What the Okay. All right.
If haters are happy about this is whatever. What is wild is commentary/react
people being cool with this, too? Yeah. I just Well, I mean,
here's the thing. Here's where it's cool. Okay. If you make a
lot of money, if you're really huge and you can't possibly be
financially hurt by this, you're pretty cool with it, right?
That's in my experience, that's what's going on. And when you
don't make a lot of money, when you are like an upand cominging
streamer in the same vertical, then you're like, "Oh, this seems
like it could be bad." Super easy to understand where the differentiation
is, right? Hold on, hold on, hold on. I'm getting I'm getting
uh
getting offers of propaganda from somebody real quick. One second.
Hold on. That's it. If anything makes them look bad is the most
forced thing I've ever seen. Exactly. Yeah. What's he going to
do? Defame me and then sue me for not suing him for defamation?
What are we talking about? Yeah, he's going to sue me for not
watching the content. watch this >> after he begged me.
Anyway, gross. Let's get back to real
issues that do matter here.
Um, specifically the Harry Mden polls on Donald Trump
is out. That could put Republicans on shaky ground in the midterms
if the president's approval rating is an indicator of how they'll
do. CNN's chief data analyst Harry Enon is here. All right, give
us the goods on what this new Gallup poll says. >> I mean,
it's a disaster if it holds towards the midterm elections. And
I should note, of course, it's not alone. I mean, just take a
look here. This is Gallop. This is the longest running
>> 155K viewers are watching Candace Owens say nothing
>> so that people would wake up. And I do think that, >> dude.
Okay.